Ähm, was macht eigentlich meine
Output?
So eine
Kack-Bit-Rate, weil
Unity Media noch nicht umgestellt hat.
Omega 0.
Ich bin voll reudig, Alter.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich nicht runter
stelle auf
ein bisschen niedrigere Auflösung.
Keine Ahnung, ich lasse mal jetzt
eigentlich, ich könnte sogar höher gehen.
Was hast du denn für eine Auflösung eingestellt?
Oh, warte mal, lass mich mal gucken.
Ich glaube bloß 3,5
oder so. 3,6.
Was, 3,6 was?
3.600
KWS und
Ach, 3.600, das wird übelst pixeln
gleich. Nö, ich hab's gerade
an, so schlicht. Ja, ja, ja, Standbild.
Warte mal, wenn sich das bewegt,
wenn sich das bewegt, dann
wird das übelst, wird das übelst.
Hä, das ist ja kein PC-Game, oder?
Ich kann doch nochmal umstellen.
Moment, warte mal, du hast ja nur 720p, ne?
No.
Warte mal. Das mache ich auch, weil
ich hab, ich hab 1.080.
Ich hab 1.000, 1.900,
ne, warte mal, skaliert auf
1.280 mal 720.
Naja, das muss ich auch noch umstellen.
Nicht stumm. Ah, moin Leute.
Was geht?
Das ist jetzt einfach so, warte mal, so scheiße
sieht das, kannst du ja immer noch umstellen.
Warte mal, wo, wo, ich muss gerade mal
kurz hier, rescale?
Ich glaube, ich muss das gleich, gleich umstellen.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Leute, also, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, wie es qualimäßig
ist und ihr müsst mal gucken, wie es von der
Lautstärke her passt.
Willst du jetzt schon starten, oder was?
Was, game?
Ha? Ja, oder?
Sonst gehen wir nochmal ins Bootcamp und
spielen noch. Ja, genau, ne, lass mal kurz warten,
bis Twitch und so alles Ankündigungen verschickt hat.
So, Leute, wie ist so die Lautstärke?
Wie ist die Lautstärke von mir? Wie ist die Lautstärke
vom Frasier?
Warum spiele ich eigentlich den, eigentlich den
Nasier?
Tja, come on, Braum.
Zu null.
Naja, gut. Du kannst sogar diesen
komischen Roboter spielen, irgendwie. Guck mal, ich kann
auf diesen Dings switchen. Warum soll ich so, warum soll ich den Roboter
spielen? Das ist voll... Wahrscheinlich kannst du dir dann
eins nice in den Finger. Ich hab, ich hab letztens,
ich hab bei, bei Dan's Gaming reingeguckt
und der Roboter stirbt. Ne, macht
er nicht. Spoiler. Spoiler!
Der Raketen-Karl hat
subscribed. Dankeschön. Pock.
Leute, ich werd mich
heute mal ein bisschen zurückhalten mit übertriebenem
Memespam oder sonst was, weil das ist
mir zu viel im Kopf, ne.
Was, Memespam? Du meinst, das ist ein Meme?
Deine Buttons smashen, oder was?
Das ist mir zu viel, mit dir im Discord
ingame auf einem anderen
Bildschirm dann irgendwie noch 50 Knöpfe
eh schon drücken müssen.
Das ist mir zu viel. Ich mach mal deinen Streamer
und dann gucken wir, wie das bei dir aussieht.
Sonius 490, nice.
What the fuck, wo ist deine Cam?
Ja, guck mal, hier hab ich meine Cam.
Viel zu, viel zu lau, das Sound.
Bei dir sieht's halt wirklich besser,
aus. Ja, aber wart mal in Bewegung,
wart mal. Hier, ich geh mal, guck dir das
mal an, ich geh mal ins Boot, ne, wobei, wenn ich ins
Bootcamp geh, müssen die Lobby wieder zumachen.
Also, Leute, wir müssen mal gucken,
wie die Quali ist. Ähm,
es kann sein, dass ich nochmal Stream
neu starten muss. Ihr müsst mir das sagen
im Chat dann, ne. Also, ob ich
nochmal Stream neu starten muss. Ja, mach doch,
geh doch nochmal ins Bootcamp. Bootcamp,
dann müssen wir die Party wieder neu machen. Weil sonst
müssen wir uns jetzt erstmal drei Stunden lang
Intro-Videos machen. Ja, hast du recht.
Wart mal, ich steck's. Und dann geh ich nämlich auch
nochmal raus und gucke mal, ob die
Leute auch was hören. So, ich bin mal raus.
So, wir müssen
uns dann noch kicken? Ne.
Do you want to bring your squad with you?
No. Piss dich, Alter.
Geh weg, ey.
Der Bootcamp.
Oh, ich glaub, man spielt ein Grill, kann das sein?
Weil im Hauptmenü ist ein Grill. I don't know.
Moment, ist das
der Friseur von früher?
Nein, das ist ein anderer. Der hört sich nur
zufällig ja genauso, gehört sich bloß zufällig
genauso an. Aber das ist ein anderer.
Ja, ich mach gleich noch Twitter-Ankündigung
und das findet wahrscheinlich
Ubisoft voll dämlich, ne? So grad
Video hochgeladen für maximalen Sellout
und direkt danach was anderes gepostet,
wo die Leute lieber dahin gehen als Video gucken.
Lulve, Alter. Wublul.
Wie sieht's eigentlich bei dir
mit Emotes aus, Frisilul?
Ich hab sowas nie. Ich hab da nicht
meinen Abo-Button, du.
Wart mal, ich mach mal kurz Fullscreen bei mir
auf der anderen Seite. Kannst du ja auch mal gucken,
wie's bei mir aussieht.
Ja. Ich mein, der bewegt sich ja noch nicht,
der Dude, ne?
Ich kann die Cam nicht bewegen,
das ist Tutorial.
Nee, du musst hochgucken, warte.
Jetzt. Guck mal. Wow.
Jetzt klotz hoch.
Reverse. Reverse.
Na gut, du kannst doch ohne.
Ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der, glaube ich,
Reverse-Control spielt, ne?
Vor allem, das war aber standardmäßig eingestellt
sogar, ne? Echt?
Ja, die wissen halt, was gut ist, ey.
Ähm, als ich angefangen hab,
hier in den Tutorials zu gehen...
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Jetzt Pixels wahrscheinlich gleich.
Also, bei mir sieht's gut aus.
Ja, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Nee, jetzt Pixels, guck.
Jetzt, jetzt Pixels ist voll.
Na, wobei.
Na, wobei, es nimmt sich nicht so.
Es geht eigentlich, oder?
Ja.
Ich guck jetzt mal kurz ins OBS,
ob's irgendwie ruckelt oder so.
Ne? Passt?
Oh, mir followt jemand.
Ich müsste mal den Follower-Sound,
glaube ich, ausstellen.
Pogu.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Wie mach ich denn das?
Also, der Chat sagt, es passt alles.
Sieht alles okay aus.
Guck jetzt hier nochmal kurz,
wenn ich hier mal ein Kameraschwenk so mache.
Mein Follower-Sound ist halt übelst laut, ne?
Du kannst ja ein bisschen runter.
Wie machst du denn das?
Ja, ich glaub, das geht.
Das geht nie.
Was? Äh, doch, du musst...
Was benutzt du für ein Follower-Sound-Ding?
Steamlab?
Ja.
Dann...
Dann musst du in Steamlabs dich einloggen.
Und da hast du nen Slider.
Geht aber nicht weiter runter, oder?
Warte mal, ich guck mal schnell.
Ist's ruckelt bei dir?
Kann bei dir überhaupt nicht ruckeln.
Bei mir, also laut OBS, ist alles flüssig.
Steamlabs.
Oh, Gott.
Pog.
Pogging mit Twitch.
Autorising.
Nope.
Und der Patrick sagt grad bei dir,
dass der hört den Stream-Sound, den Follower-Sound kaum.
Echt? Na dann perfekt.
Alles gut.
So, dann wär ich jetzt...
Ach, weißt du warum?
Weil ich im OBS ja komplett OBS leise gestellt hab.
Oh, Pogu!
So, ähm, dann machen wir mal ne Sellout-Message.
Setzen wir mal ab.
Ähm...
Auf...
Machen wir mal Sellout.
Wir machen...
Denk zu mir.
Äh, ich kann einfach posten.
Posten.
Äh, du kannst auch Ausrufezeichen...
Bin ich...
Bin ich auch bei dir?
Du kannst bei mir im Chat, kannst du Ausrufezeichen Friseur machen.
Da gibt's nen...
Da gibt's nen Link.
Zum Originalen.
Nicht zu dem Fake heute, ey.
Weil ich bin mal bei dir.
Reingestellt.
Reingestellt, ey.
Ich sag, das passt schon.
Baby.
Also Leute, sieht alles gut aus, ne?
Kann man so lassen.
Falls es irgendwie übelst, äh, später irgendwie übelst ruckelt oder, oder rumpixelt, müsst
ihr Bescheid sagen, dann...
Ach so, und sagt auch, auf welchem Stream ihr dann seid, weil ich hab alle Chats auf, ich
blick da grad nur durch.
So, wir machen jetzt ein Sellout-Message.
Also.
Der Friseur...
Der könnte...
Sellout.
Eine Ankündigung verschicken.
Ich streame nun die Gears...
Ich muss mich voll dran gewöhnen, nicht mehr, nicht mehr, äh, Gears of War zu sagen, anstatt
zu...
Das ist jetzt ja Gear.
Warum?
Das ist jetzt Gears 5.
Warum eigentlich?
Die machen so ne komische, ähm, Beschneidung.
Sprich...
Beschneidung, ey.
Naja, weil es zu Gewalt...
Guck mal, diese ganzen Sachen früher...
Oh, sap, heiliger Bim Bam, dankeschön.
Was ist los, Altersen?
Oh, sap, wie sieht's...
Wie sieht's bei dir mit Affiliate oder Partner oder so aus?
Könntest du eigentlich auch machen.
Die sagen wieder, Altersen sagt schon wieder, du hörst dich genauso an wie ich.
Das ist total dumm, man.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Der Friseur und ich streamen nun Gears 5.
Poggers.
Ja.
Wollen wir jetzt Level Up aus, mein Follower-Sound rausschmeißen?
Wie kann ich denn das in Steam machen?
Ja.
Was ist das?
Ist es ein Follower-Sound?
Ja.
Das machst du einfach aus, also drehst du auf null Prozent.
Ne, aber ich hab ja noch im zweiten in der ersten Scene hab ich den ja auch drin.
Achso.
Eh…
Ja.
Du kannst das glaube ich in den Browser.
Kannst du das in den Browser machen?
Den OBS musst du in den Browser einfügen.
Wurde dann auch die Sachen ver...
Weiss ich nicht.
Boah, gute Frage.
Ja.
Ich lösche das jetzt mal raus.
Ja, dann hast du es in der ersten Szene gar nicht.
Dann lösche ich das einfach.
By the way, BDO ist am Start, Leute.
Ja, du musst ja AFK angeln, ne?
Ja, dann lösche ich das hier einfach mal raus.
Weil das ist nämlich Double-Scene, deshalb hört man das auch.
Macht das, ja.
So, und jetzt mache ich den Maximum-Sellout-Post auf YouTube.
Jetzt haben wir gleich 500 Zuschauer.
Oh, da kann ich mal gucken, ob ich noch angele.
Nice.
Oh, jetzt könnte ich sogar Black Desert, guck mal, ich kann mir Black Desert über meinen
zweiten Bildschirm auf den anderen Bildschirm ziehen.
Nee, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, du machst Bild in Bild, gehst du und angelstrebst.
Wenn euch das zu gewalttätig ist, könnt ihr angelstrebend gucken.
So, jetzt, genau, das wäre auch witzig, könnte eigentlich mal...
Family-Friendly, schreibst du Family-Friendly rein.
Irgendwie postest du das?
Ich poste das Ding auf YouTubie nix.
Sagt es der Carsten eigentlich immer noch?
Weiß ich nicht.
YouTubie?
Leute, ich kann auf YouTube in der Community nix posten, was ist denn da schon wieder los,
hä?
Äh, Second-Decal, what?
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Alter, ey, wir mal loslegen, ne?
Ja, drei Stunden, ne?
Aber jetzt können wir anfangen.
Wir haben...
Ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich, ich,
ich, ichем tuna.
Ey, du hast John Marie angefangen.
Ich, ich, ich, ich imalte dich, ich imalte dich zum, zum Poggern.
Das wird gebached!
Gebashed, ich gebashed halt damit jetzt.
So, invite...
Warum lag dit so?
Ach, ne, man muss ja den komischen anderen...
Ach, irgendjemand wollte wissen?
Ich glaube,'m Finn.
Woher auf einmal die Tattoos?
Ja, man geht zum Tätowieren und lässt sich rechen.
Aber wat?
Ich kann nicht immer einladen.
Huh?
Warum nicht?
Weil InvitePlayer nimmer funktioniert.
Plopp, nix. mal aufbau, InvitePlayer.
Warte, ich gehe ins Menü.
Nee, das liegt nicht an dir.
Weil?
Weiß ich nicht.
Gebarkt.
Gebarkt, ja.
Kann nix mehr entwalten.
Ich mach jetzt das Game einfach nochmal.
Wie macht man überhaupt Games aus?
Hier, Game Options.
Quit.
Huge.
So, jetzt aber hoffentlich geht es jetzt.
Sag mal, Leute, wer hat sich das eigentlich ausgedacht, ne?
Das, das, äh, komische Xbox-Menü.
Das ist übelst.
Das ist ein Crack.
I don't know.
Ist das Game rausgekommen?
Ich lese mal bei dir im Chat mit.
Ja.
Heute, oder?
Gestern.
Ich glaube, offiziell.
Nee, heute.
Aber gestern konnte ich es schon.
Offiziell heute, ja.
Und, übrigens, Leute, ganz wichtig.
Wenn ihr das spielen wollt, egal ob auf Xbox oder PC,
ihr könnt das aktuell für einen Euro spielen.
Ihr müsst einfach mit dem Xbox, wie heißt der Scheiß?
Ultimate Xbox, Ultimate Premium Pass.
Oder irgend so was.
Abschließen.
Der ist gerade 92 Prozent reduziert.
Und dann könnt ihr das abschließen.
Direkt canceln, aber Gears runterladen, weil es inklusive ist.
Das ist hier.
Huge Brain.
Oder du machst es eh schon und kostest 70 Euro.
Ich hab das schon gesehen, ne?
Kann man auch machen.
Kann man auch YOLO.
Five Head.
Aber die Frage ist, kannst du es denn unendlich weiterspielen?
Nein.
Wenn du den ...
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also, das ist für mich gut zum Kampagnespielen.
Für dich ist das nicht gut.
Genau.
Weil ich müsste ja jeden Monat ...
Du würdest sogar mehr Geld ausgeben.
Genau.
Du würdest ja nämlich noch mal kaufen.
Ja.
Das sagt ja der Teil.
Äh, Moment.
Moment.
Was?
YouTube ...
Was ist los?
YouTube hat meinen Streamlink nicht mit kopiert.
Moment.
Scammer.
Was das ...
Will YouTube nicht mal, dass man ...
... dass man irgendwelche Sachen ...
Wahrscheinlich, dass du keine Werbung mehr machst, oder was?
Ey, das wär ...
Ey, das wär übelst der Fail.
Boah, das wär ...
Da hörst du gleich wieder mit YouTube auf.
Ich hab ja gehört, in deinem Stream, dass du jetzt richtiger YouTuber wieder wirst.
Richtig, ja.
Ja.
So.
Na ja.
So Carsten-Styles wird's Geldknapp.
Lol, genau.
Wir verarschen YouTube jetzt.
Wir pasten das einfach hinten dran.
Poggers.
Ihr Beitrag erstellen.
Jetzt hat er's.
Jetzt hat er's richtig ...
Jetzt hat er's kapiert.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Ähm, steht oben.
Gears of War 5.
Doppel.
Gazza.
Campaign.
New.
Save.
So, jetzt kann ich dich inviten.
Hoffe ich.
Da sieht man mal wieder, dass man mit professionellen YouTubern spielt, weil ...
... das dauert dann ewig, je mehr man anfängt.
Drei, drei Stunden, ja.
Ich weiß noch früher das alte Xbox-Menü.
Hast du aufgemacht, hast die Leute eingeklickt und dann wurden sie invited.
Jetzt musstest du selecten und musst dann sagen, invite selected people.
Ja.
Gears of War-ten trifft's besser.
Break Gears of War.
Ja.
Patrick wieder am Flame, by the way.
Nice.
Es muss.
So, hast du gekriegt?
Invite?
Hello.
Ha?
Hast du Invite gekriegt?
Ach so, gar nicht drauf geachtet, warte.
Nice.
Ups.
Warte, warte, warte.
Wo war denn das jetzt?
Äh ...
Hier, ich glaube hier.
Nee.
Irgendwo, irgendwo ...
Ist das das Xbox-Menü?
Kannst du sagen, Freunde oder so?
Ich hab flirre nichts.
Friends.
Ich schick dir einfach nochmal einen.
Warte, warte, ich hab, ich hab.
Hast du?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich wünsch.
Waiting.
Hast du eigentlich so eine neue Xbox oder noch die alte Xbox?
Ich hab die alte.
Ich hab's auch nicht eingesehen, mir eine neue zu kaufen.
Weil ich mein, wie, wie oft hattest du die an?
Seit du sie gekauft hast?
Keine Ahnung, seit vier Jahren hab ich sie nicht mehr angehabt.
Okay, ähm, was spielen wir denn für eine Schwierigkeit?
Ja, irgendwas so mittel, weil wir zacken mit dem Controller.
Intermediate?
Ja, irgendwie so.
Experience, Insane, Beginner, Intermediate spielen wir.
Wir müssen ja Insane dann eh nochmal drüber spielen.
Ich, ich mach Start, jetzt müssen wir uns Cutscene angucken.
Dann müssen wir die Klappe halten, weil die Leute sonst immer sagen, redet nicht immer so viel während der Cutscene.
Warte, hier schreibt, hier fragt noch jemand, wie lange war deine Xbox nicht mehr an?
Na, ich glaube vier Jahre oder so.
Drei, vier Jahre oder so.
Haha.
Aber hauptsache erst mal wieder kaufen, ne?
Ja.
Kann ich starten?
Ha?
Ja.
Bashen, Alter.
Zersägen.
Das wird sicher.
Ich glaube, man kann nämlich nicht mehr zersägen.
Ob es auch wieder den Resonator gibt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also erst, erstes wird zersägt.
Aha.
Warum, ey, YouTube ist übelst fail, Alter, was ist das?
Du kannst, du kannst mittlerweile keine Twitch-Messages mehr gescheit einführen.
Das ist übelst reudig, Alter.
YouTubee.
YouTubee, genau.
Ich fühle mich so richtig Oldschool-Konsole.
Ja, das ist toll.
Headset auf dem Kopf, by the way.
Übelst, übelst nice.
Und überkrank.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Warum habe ich mein Video gerade an?
So.
Jetzt aber.
Eigene, eigene Views pushen in Dauerschleife, oder was?
Haha, genau.
So, Leute, ihr müsst mal gucken.
Oh, ne, jetzt müssen wir die Klappe halten.
Lol.
Cocks werden protected.
Ist der Sound laut genug?
Zu leise?
Ist es zu laut bei mir oder zu leise, Freunde?
Bisschen lauter, mache ich.
Aha.
Du merkst, Jin kommt zurück, oder?
Wir müssen jetzt weg.
Mutter!
Hey, hör auf.
Du musst verstecken und dann musst du fliehen.
Hä?
Digger, wenn ich bei mir frage, na, kommen nur Trolls.
Ich weiß am Ende immer nie, ob es zu leise oder zu laut ist.
By the way.
Also, wie ich das jetzt raushöre, ist okay jetzt.
Passt.
Du weißt, wie gut ich es tue, dass er helfen kann.
Ach, den gibt es ja immer noch.
Dad, du solltest dir das ansehen.
Ich dachte, du hättest gesagt, du würdest nicht aus dem Auto fliehen.
Du spielst doch auf Englisch, oder?
Ja.
Ich checke die Gears-Story null mittlerweile.
Einfach bashen.
Einfach bashen, ja.
Oh, wird gesagt.
Ja.
Nee, du hast den letzten Teil auch nicht gespielt, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe den letzten Teil kaum nicht gespielt.
Weil ich checke gar nicht, wer die Leute sind.
Ja.
Bäm.
Ja, ich...
Das...
Da...
Das muss sein.
Sag mal, ist das sowas wie, was bisher geschah?
Hm...
Könnte sein.
Leute, ist das sowas wie, was bisher geschah?
Ich stand am Anfang.
Ja, am Anfang habe ich in Settings rumgebastelt.
Stimmt, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Haben wir nicht so einen Typ in irgendeinem Gears-Star aus...
...gerettet?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Bäschen.
Bist du noch da?
Ja, ja.
Ich bin völlig geflasht.
Das ist vom vier...
Ach, das war, was im vierten Teil passiert ist.
Siehste?
Also, wir haben im Prinzip nichts verpasst.
Hast du das nie gespielt?
Sogar gestreamt?
Den vierten?
Aber nicht mit mir.
Ja.
Ich war es nicht.
Äh...
Glaube ich nicht.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ne...
...finde ich die Story von Gears eh kacke.
Wieso? Bist du doof?
Warum? Was...
Was ist alles...
Gears-Story-Beste?
Na, Aliens?
Wollen die Weltherrschaft...
Ja, das ist das einzig Gute da dran.
Hallo?
Ich finde...
Bist du sorry?
...wenn ich mir so Leute angucke, irgendwie so wie Markus Phoenix und so...
...das ist so der schlechteste Actionheld überhaupt.
Ach, du hast ja keine Ahnung.
Kack-Noob.
Aber, aber Tracer...
Immer haten, immer haten, ne?
Immer haten, genau.
Bei dir fragt jemand, warum kein, äh, WoW-Classic-Stream?
Omega-Lol.
WoW-Classic.
Wenn ich WoW-Classic streame, dann mach ich kein YouTube mehr.
Und kein Stream mehr.
Und nix mehr.
Der Composer, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ist das nicht der Game-of-Thrones-Typ?
Das wisst ihr doch bestimmt.
Chat ist, ist, ist schlau.
Big-Brain-Chat.
Decade ist das.
Decade.
Wer ist Decade überhaupt?
Das bist du.
Das bin ich jetzt aktuell, ja.
Das ist der Bert.
Nee.
Oh, der Bert.
Da isser.
Ich will Bert spielen, by the way.
Der Bert ist da.
Bert-Beste.
Vor allem, ich hab immer noch Bert als, als mein Profilbild, ne?
Echt?
Stimmt, auf Twitch.
Bei Twitch, ne?
Auf Twitch hast du immer noch den Bert.
Leute, habt ihr irgendeine Ahnung?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Weißt du, wer das ist?
So, ist Decade hier?
Ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer hier was ist.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich kenn bloß den Typ.
Wobei, die ist nach Injudgment auch gewesen.
Ist die das?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Sollen wir losgehen hier?
Welchen, Alter?
Ich will, ich will segnen.
Du kriegst wahrscheinlich eh nur so ne komische Startpistole.
Kannste erst mal nix segnen.
Jetzt, es lädt.
Es lädt.
I freezy left the game steht da gerade.
Ich freezy left the game, Leute.
Läufts bei dir weiter?
Ne, bei mir lädt's.
Oh, oh.
Oh, Oh.
Gott.
Arme.
Hey, hey.
Ich will da, ich will da, ich will da.
Oh, oh.
Ich will da.
Ich will, ich will da.
Oh, oh.
Oh Gott!
Xbox, Alter!
Wer weiß, was es ist.
Ich lade dich gleich wieder an.
Ich habe dich gekickt, oder was?
Nee.
Ich entweih dich, sobald die komische Katze hier vorbei ist.
Ich hoffe, wir müssen nicht nochmal starten und uns das nochmal angucken.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach bei dir.
Ist der Friseur eigentlich noch Friseur?
Nee.
Alter, sag dich mit Bashing!
Ja, es läuft eh noch die Zwischensequenz.
Mega-Lol, ey.
So fehl, dass du gleich rausfliehst.
Jetzt wird sich erstmal abgezahlt.
Okay.
Ich gucke bei dir einfach.
Jetzt entweih dich mal.
Game Options.
Fuck, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht.
Was?
Social.
RT muss ich drücken.
Komm, entweih mich.
RT, ja.
I Frisi.
Select.
Invite.
Hast du gekriegt?
Aber du bist schon in Game, oder was?
Ja, in dem, wo wir gerade gestartet haben.
Ja, perfekt.
Da haben wir gar nicht viel gepasst, außer dass wir uns abseilen.
Ich bleibe jetzt beim Abseilen hängen, bis du gejoint bist.
Kannst du joinen?
Ja.
Macht Spaß.
Ich bin da.
Okay.
Slidest du gerade runter?
Bla, bla, bla.
Nee, ich bin bei...
Ich muss jetzt hier irgendwo...
Okay, ich warte, bis du wieder ingame bist.
Kann man das auf PC zocken, ja?
Für einen Euro gerade.
Aber ich hab mal gehört, dass es mit
Abstützen aktuell jetzt so
rare ist.
Okay.
Aber Connection Lost wäre schon Fail.
Okay, es lädt.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Freesy, enter the game.
Oh, toll.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt. Wie ging das weiter?
Weil wenn es lädt...
Dann dauert es immer so lange.
Warte, dann stürzt es ab oder sowas?
Nee, dann dauert es immer so lange.
Dann dauert es so lange.
Irgendwie so.
Trotzdem, man seilt sich auch ab, wenn man nach oben drückt.
Das ist nicht...
Nicht immersive.
Oh, jetzt, ich seile.
Wo bist du? Ich seh dich nicht seilen.
Ich muss seilen. Ich komm runter, Dude.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Ich bin unterwegs.
Ach, du bist schon runter.
Unter mir seile.
Ich seile gerade.
Ja, ja, ich seh dich.
Ich seh dich seilen.
Vor allem bei mir passt es auch, ne?
Mit dem Abseilen.
By the way.
You know what I mean.
Ich hab die passende E-Mails für alles im Streber.
Ach, guck mal, jetzt ist die Sensitivity okay.
Komisch.
Merkwürdig, das Zeug.
Okay, A gedrückt halten, weil Rennbar geerst.
Genau.
So.
Geiler Phoenix.
Da bist du.
Du bist das?
Ja, ich seh, da ist die Stellenprobe.
Genau, man kann.
Das ist die Kate.
Aber man kann nicht.
Ich muss mal gucken, wegen Controller-Settings und so.
Und das ist Dave.
Dave fliegt da oben.
Ah.
Der ist.
Sag, wenn du ready bist, mit Settings.
Ja, du.
Nee, ich hab gar nicht gemacht.
Es geht los.
Wow.
Warum move ich so dumm und du hinstalt hier?
Hallo?
Ich kann's nicht.
Also ich kann nur mit A springen.
Kannst du auch mit A springen?
Nee.
Weil ich kann auch nicht schnell rennen.
Hä, warum läuft der so dumm?
Slider End kann ich machen.
Ja, das ist auch das Einzige, was ich machen kann.
Der läuft nicht schnell.
Achso.
Okay, okay.
Das ist Story-Intro-Sequenz.
Aber es sieht schon gut aus
im Vergleich zu den alten Gears.
Ah gut, die haben auch eine Hardware,
die ist doppelt so schnell, ne?
Ja.
Check mal, ob Teamkill an ist.
Nee.
RT ist nachladen, genau.
Sehr gut.
Oh, mein Aim ist richtig sauber.
Ich glaub, ich bin schon leer,
bevor überhaupt Jäger kommen, by the way.
Oh, kein Intro.
Ja, aber wir kriegen die Satelliten ab,
wir können den Sturm von Morbid ausbrüllen.
Komm, wir rennen jetzt einfach hier lang.
Hey, komm zurück!
Oh, Skane will nicht, dass wir hier lang rennen.
Nein.
Es will Cinematic, Cinematic machen.
Wir können den Lech verwenden.
Du kannst, doch, du kannst mir den Prime-Sub-Emote verwenden, klar.
Es sieht ein bisschen...
...fremd.
Du musst vielleicht mal refreshen.
Na, halb so große Pläne sind ein bisschen Baird-Spezialität.
Ich hab Belfield Revolution hier.
Mein Vater, bevor er gestorben ist,
hat er Baird auf ein paar Kogs Geheimnisse eingeladen.
Und diese Insel hat viele davon.
Aus Lied.
Y. Da steht nicht, soll Y drücken.
Passiert nix.
Passiert aber nix.
Ah, das ist der Dave, der den Gegner highlightet, oder so.
Ja.
Ah.
Ey, ich frag mich, warum ich nicht rennen kann.
Nee, nee, nicht.
Kannst du richtig rennen? Bei mir läuft der immer nur so.
Ja, doch, guck hier. Ich kann.
Hey, da drüben.
AIM-LT-HOLD-X-TO-HAVE-DAVE-RETRIEVE-PICKUP
Ah, jetzt kann man den Dave da hinschicken.
Okay, Dave. Mach mal.
Geiler Flieger-End hier, der Dave.
Grenade.
Da haben wir weggecrapped.
Stell dir mal vor, der Carsten wird jetzt mitspielen.
Die Granate, die wär noch nicht mal über den Abgrund drüber.
Da wär die schon weg.
Doch, guck mal, da ist noch Ammo.
Kannst du Ammo aufnehmen dann?
Wenn du das aufnimmst, ist es dann weg?
Ah, ne. Doch.
Custom. Kein Custom-Loot.
Ich muss da mal in den Options ganz kurz gucken.
Frag mich, ob das auf der Xbox, äh, wie heißt das?
X? S?
Ne. X. Also die neue, die schnellere.
Ob das da viel besser aussieht,
oder ob es kaum unterschied ist.
Keine Ahnung. Boah, da liegt was.
Okay, jetzt kann ich rennen.
Geiles Poster.
Oh, weißt du noch, wo wir in Gears 1
Achievements gemacht haben?
Ne, das müssen wir hier wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Oh, guck mal, Sägen. Hier, für dich.
Säge. Säg.
Du darfst sägen.
Alter, yes.
R'n'B.
Säge-App.
Maritim Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Ich will aber Leute zersägen
und nicht diese Dinger hier.
Ja, das kommt vielleicht noch.
Aber weißt du noch in Gears 1, wo wir das erste Poster
übersehen haben und drei Stunden oder
drei Tage oder so gesucht haben?
Ja.
Cinematic. 30 FPS.
FabiGangster
hat subscribed.
Danke. Nice.
Pock.
Oh, wir dürfen richtig laufen.
Wir dürfen richtig laufen. Nice.
Oh, da sind Gegner.
Direkt neben uns. Pock.
Oh, ich seh es. LOL.
Warte mal. Ah, ah. Cover.
Ja, so ging das. Genau. Okay.
Wie die Kackenhofs für die größten Geißlose.
Konnte man nicht irgendwie
ranzoomen mit RTLT?
Nee, gell? Oder?
Doch.
Alter, ich bin die Shotgun.
Haben wir eine? Oh, geil. Wir haben die Shotgun. Das ist geil.
Haben wir jetzt irgendwas geworfen?
Fuck.
Okay, ich bin der übelste.
Alter, ich hab die Steuerung 0 drauf.
Wir werden gebasht.
Aber eigentlich ist das richtig oldschool, ne?
Weil das erste Game, was wir richtig gesuchtet haben,
Coop auf der 360 war Gears 4 1.
Weißt du noch?
Und wo ich dann quasi
nach dem dritten Mal durchspielen ungefähr den Controller benutzen konnte.
Nach dem dritten Mal durchspielen ungefähr den Controller benutzen konnte.
Wir haben das Ganze gar nicht mehr richtig.
Hast du Gore an?
Muss man das looten oder lootet man automatisch?
Ah, nee, hier.
Irgendwie stimmt meine Steuerung noch nicht.
Zoomst du ran, wenn du RT drückst?
Ja.
Echt?
Was zoomt man denn ran, wenn ich RT drücke?
Was hast du denn eingestellt?
Äh, Default.
Ich stell jetzt auf. Was hast du eingestellt?
Classic, Options,
Controller, Controlling Scheme.
Ah, hast du gerade
eingehalten oder was? Ja, ich, was hast du
eingestellt? Classic? Ne.
Classic Alt?
Classic, ne? Classic Alt?
Aber das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Ne, das ruft nicht ran,
wenn du LT, RT drückst.
Was auch immer.
Ich bleib jetzt auf Default, das
passt glaube ich noch am besten.
Ah.
Fashion. Wo bist du hin?
Da.
So hier durch?
Ah, hier müssen wir lang.
Warum?
Das Game gilt's auch für PC, ja.
Warum machst du das nicht?
Warum muss das die Kate machen?
Ich war gerade weit weg.
Ich glaube,
das Game will, dass die Kate das macht.
Die müssen uns zeigen, dass auch Frauen Gitter
heben können.
Monkatos.
Warum spielen wir die Xbox aus Nostalgiegründen?
Ne.
Warum spielen wir nochmal Xbox?
Ha, weil Gears, Gears, Gears.
Ach, weil Multiplayer und so, ne?
Ja, wegen Multiplayer. Ich meine, du kannst doch auf dem PC
Gears zocken, aber...
Vielleicht ist das ja sogar Crossplay.
Ähm, Leute, die auf irgendwas gehen in der Richtung, aber...
Okay, Active Reload, klappt schon mal.
So muss das sein.
Oh, jetzt wird er gebasht. Alter, jetzt wird er gebasht.
Bäm.
Bashen. Jawoll.
So ist das gut.
Huge Bash.
Oh, Shotgun. Shotgun.
Okay, ich sehe gerade, ne? Du kannst den nicht direkt
äh, direkt umbashen.
Komplett. Oh, ich habe keine Muni mehr.
Fuck.
Oh, mein Huge Aim im Controller, ey.
Das ist bei mir genauso.
So, jetzt kommt Shotgun hier raus.
Bäm.
So muss das sein.
Mal erstmal schön looten.
Lebt hier noch was?
Ja.
Ja, komm mal hier bashen.
Oh.
Guck mal, ich bin gerade als Schutz, den kann man da auch...
Zack.
So, ist das gut.
Ah, das muss gebasht werden.
Du musst looten noch.
Soll ich auch fahren?
Oder hast du genug Ammo?
Ne, Nesha habe ich...
Habe ich genug.
Stimmt, du spielst ja Shotgun auch nicht, ne?
Ne, hier kann ich nicht.
Ne.
Die rennen schneller als in den alten Games.
Ne, die rennen langsamer meiner Meinung nach.
Der flitzt, der flitzt voller Flitzer.
Hier, guck mal.
Das Handling nach Left, Right ist nicht mehr so klobig, aber...
Voller, voller...
Rennmäßig finde ich irgendwie langsamer.
Ja, ich finde, der flitzt voll.
Oh, hier, Segen.
Oh, Segen, Segen.
Moment, wo bist du?
Komm, seg mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo du bist.
Ach, da.
Ach, hier, das komische Ding.
Left, äh, LMB oder was?
Segen, Segen.
RB, RB.
Oh, hier, krasse Wege, ey.
Das ist aber...
Das ist aber nur Kabelsägen.
Kabelsägen ist, äh...
Low.
Vielleicht kann ich dich gleich sehen.
Ja.
Schließ dir mal aus und Tastatur in die Xbox an.
Ich glaube, das geht bei dem Game nicht.
Echt?
Kannst du Glöbbel machen.
What?
Da brauche ich aber komischen...
Das ist ja gerade das Sinn...
Das ist ja gerade das Sinn bei Gears,
dass du mit dem...
...Kontroller spielst, weil das Setting,
zumindest war es früher so,
selbst auf dem PC,
mit dem Controller einfach smoother ist.
Gerade wenn du so um die Ecken stelzen würdest.
Also so wie ich gerade mit dem Controller spiele,
ist der gerade nicht smoother, ey.
Warum spielst du auf Englisch?
Äh...
Deutsch.
Weil, weil...
Ich sag nur so,
in dein Gesicht zur Hölle, ja.
Genau, das reicht schon.
Guck mal, ich bin Bouncing.
Bouncing Queen.
Ja.
Multiplayer geht ab.
Oh, Achtung, Ink.
Vor allem Ink, ja.
Huge Controller-Aim.
Alter, ich gehe da jetzt rein hier.
Nasher.
Ich bin gebasht.
Der Nasher basht.
Ich war jetzt mit Active Reload jetzt so richtig...
Bam.
Na gut.
...im Gesicht.
Und der, den dreckigen...
Alter.
Wow.
Explodieren die?
Das könnte sogar sein, dass die explodieren.
Ich glaube, die explodieren.
Wo ist Shotgun?
Shotgun.
Bashen.
Shotgun Active Reload.
Bashen, Alter.
Bam.
Next.
Oh, f**k.
Der hat ganz schön Damage gemacht gerade.
Ja, die explodieren.
Da muss man echt aufpassen.
Hatte man nicht immer so ein Gears-Logo sonst im...?
Ah ja, ich hab' ein Pistol.
Hatte man nicht immer so ein Gears-Logo in der Mitte,
womit man gut Shotguns healen kann?
Boah.
Ich glaube es war ein Multiplayer oder so.
Alter Headshots.
Oh. Wo wird gesägt? Kann man den sägen?
Simp.
Den sägen.
Oh da gibt's Loot. Da gibt's Loot.
Ich will Polenzer.
Bäm.
Echt freeload. Zack. Bäm.
Oh ich hab freeload bekommen.
Da kommen ganz schön viele gerade.
Das werden ein bisschen viele oder?
Geht schon.
Ah jetzt.
Oh mein Controller ey. Alter.
Das ist voll schlecht.
Ich treffe überhaupt nichts.
Gibt's hier Loot?
Irgendwo ein bisschen Ammo oder so?
Ah hier guck mal.
Hier gibt's einen Red Polenzer irgendwo.
Da müsste schon mal ein Shotgun dagegen austauschen. Will ich das denn?
Ja komm.
Naja im Game ist halt.
Alter das ist nicht dein Ernst ne?
Kannst doch. Ne ne.
Du kannst doch nie die Shotgun alter.
Shotgun ist das Beste.
Da gibt's bestimmt einfach in jeder Ecke
neue Shotgun.
Du musst dir bloß mal eine Shotgun da liegen lassen.
Wenn es wieder einige gibt.
Hier gibt's die Säge Action.
Ne der Dave. Der Dave muss was machen.
Oh Dave.
Gibt's Loot.
Come on brah.
Der Red Polenzer
ist ähm.
Nicht mal Gears of War 1 gewesen.
Wie kann der dann Retro sein?
Big Big Brain.
Wow.
Jetzt wird geslidet.
Alter ich will mitsliden.
Du bist halt.
Du hast dich runterteleportiert.
Exakt.
Ammo.
Guck mal da gibt's eine.
Eine Hammer Burst.
Braucht keiner.
Was muss man hier machen?
Mr. Duxor.
Alter was muss ich machen?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Warte wir müssten den Dave fragen wahrscheinlich.
Ah hier einfach X drücken.
Einfach angucken und X drücken.
Oh.
Ja gut.
Nice Aim.
Guck mal da sind die anderen Dudes.
Chat macht sich über unser Aim lustig.
Das war ne Stels Mission.
Ja egal warum.
Lull.
Die wiffige Stels.
Oh jetzt war mal ne Granate.
Jawoll.
Huge Frag.
Oh.
Das war nicht meine Frag.
Meine Frag ist voll zu Füßen gelandet.
Ist nix passiert.
Ich glaub da vorne steht so ein Boom.
So ein Boom Shot.
Ja.
Der macht das fette Ding.
Sag mal kannst du ranzoomen mit RT?
Also ich mein.
Ne ne ne ich mein mit dem Stick.
Nicht mit RT.
Ich laber drum aus Zeug.
Von links links links.
Oh fuck.
Ich komm zu dir.
Genau komm.
Du musst schneller.
Du musst schnell zu mir.
Was muss ich drücken?
X.
Fuck.
Wie viel war denn da so übrig?
Ich weiß nicht ob das nen Timer hat oder so.
Ah das war einfach ein bisschen Panik gemacht.
Ja.
Ne es gab nen Timer.
Oh hier ist ein Granatenwerfer.
Achtung Granatenwerfer.
Huge.
Jawoll.
So muss das sein.
Hier liegen noch Granaten rum.
Hier ist so ein Retrolenser hier.
Hammer Burst will keiner.
Oh was ist denn das?
Kann man hier runter? Oh da kommt was vor uns.
Der Retrolenser
verzieht ja so nach oben.
Boah den müssen wir
zertreten den Dude hier.
Ich glaub ich nehm doch mal Hammer Burst.
Ja. Nice.
Schön Segoas.
Boah das ist so nice wie die platzen.
Oh ich glaub ich hab
grad Friendly Fire.
Gibt's Friendly Fire?
Weiß ich nicht.
Die nehmen doch gar nicht so viel Damage.
Wenn man rangeht.
Der ist geiler
Oh Huge Aim wieder.
Komm jetzt Shotgun.
Ah ich hab gar keine Shotgun mehr.
Ist der hinter uns gewesen?
Ne.
Komm Ypsilon. Der Dave. Der Dave muss pulsen.
Jawoll. Dave hat gepulst.
So. Achtung.
Achtung jetzt.
Bam.
Ich glaub ich bin zu weit. Oh Gott.
Wo bist du?
Der ist gerade gebombt.
Was?
Bist du noch da?
Jaja.
Das Ding hält ganz schön viel aus.
Ich hab gar nicht so ein Ding reingehauen.
Alter warum hält das so viel aus?
Ich bin down.
Alter. Alter. Alter. Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Ich glaub ich hab einfach noch nicht gecheckt.
Achso drück ganz schnell A.
Ich weiß nicht ob das noch geht wie früher.
Oh wo bist du denn?
Hinten.
Ich kann da nicht hoch.
Da kann man ja mal hoch.
Was sagt der da?
Oh Gott.
Du bist doch. Oh ne.
Bist du gestorben oder was?
Ok reload.
Next.
Ah ok. Wenn einer stirbt dann.
Also der Chat sagt einfach reinballern.
Er nimmt 2012.
Einfach reinballern.
Also typische Gears Taktik.
Die Fliegeflieger soll man noch schießen.
Was irgendwie logisch erscheint.
Weil die haben dieses Lavascheiß da.
Die Fliegeflieger.
Und dann das fette Vieh.
Ja.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal die kleinen Clear.
Bevor wir da runter hüpfen.
Nice. Huge aim.
Massive.
Hammerburst auch ey.
Es ist geil wie man in ein paar Jahren
so zum absoluten Aim
Kack Noob werden kann.
Oft ja mit dem Controller.
Ich mein was ist das hier?
Was ist das?
Guck mal jetzt kann man den Dave da hinschicken.
Der holt einem das.
Ich hau da einfach die Dinger hin.
Ich Boomshot den Dude einfach.
Bam.
Der hat Damage gekriegt aber.
Nicht viel ne.
Muss man da vielleicht von hinten drauf schießen?
Das ist doch vielleicht so ne Gears Taktik.
Wo man von hinten drauf schießen muss.
Ah ok easy.
Check.
Ich geh mal hinter dem gucken.
Ob man da von hinten drauf schießen muss.
Guck mal ob du von hinten drauf ballern kannst.
Hatte ich auch so ein kleines Ding wie ich getroffen.
Ja.
Ja einfach drauf ballern.
Ok guck mal ob das mit von hinten funktioniert.
Kappa Pride.
Ne Storm Shop.
Oh fuck.
Da kommt er mir.
Warum macht das so viel Damage?
Ach der hat jetzt irgendwie so.
Was ist das denn für ein Vieh?
Was?
Erstmal looten.
Der liegt noch irgendwie.
For grades.
Erstmal looten.
Da ist noch Ammo glaube ich.
Oh die laufen an immer so.
Irgendwie hab ich meine Steuerung noch nicht so richtig.
Irgendwie hat mich dieses Ding ins.
Ich bin übrigens.
Ich bin übrigens voll dämlich ne.
Das mit dem RT also mit dem.
Ich meine gar nicht RT mit dem rechten Stick.
Ranzoomen das war Uncharted das war gar nicht.
War gar nicht ähm.
Hier ist so vor.
Uncharted konntste ranzoomen und noch ein Stück ranzoomen.
Wo gehts denn lang?
Ja.
Lol der Frasier.
Den gibts noch ja.
Der streamt auch.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Friseur oder Ausrufezeichen Frisi.
Eins von beiden.
Dann gibts Chat.
Den Channel.
Wo ist der Dave? Der Dave muss das jetzt machen.
Dave komm.
Ich glaube wir sollen da außen rumlaufen.
Ich glaube wir sollen da außen rumstelzen.
Du kannst doch den Dave dort reinschicken.
In diesen komischen.
Echt?
Ich dachte vielleicht irgendwie.
Ich glaube man muss da außen rumlaufen.
Frisi mit Y.
Ah es ist ich hab es.
Echt?
Du musst da einfach nur aimen.
Und dann kommt der Typ.
Dann stellst du da rein.
Big brain.
Oh ich bin wieder da.
Ey Dilly can't backseat gaming dude.
Die haben uns immer über so Leute lustig gemacht.
Die Let's Play noch nicht spielen können.
Oder?
Ist doch so.
Aber ich sag dir.
In spätestens 2 Missionen gehen wir wieder ab.
Easy.
Hier.
Ich hab Retro Lancer.
Alter ich hab meine Näsche gekroppt.
Nein.
Shotgun crapped.
Der Karsten hat es gecrapped.
Easy.
Hammer Burst.
Hier hättest du bestimmt noch irgendwelches Stelzzeug zum sammeln.
Garantiert.
Aber wie ist das bist du noch irgendwie auf Achievement sammeln oder so?
Ne aber außer bei Gears hab ich eigentlich immer versucht alles komplett zu machen.
Warte.
Oh ein Cocktag.
Alter es gibt noch Cocks.
Cocktags.
Hier ist richtig viel.
Brauchst du noch Ammo oder so?
Macht der Dave für dich auch Licht oder macht der nur bei mir Licht?
Ich glaub der Dave macht nur bei mir Licht.
Wo ist denn der?
Ne der hat hier Licht.
Der macht für mich auch Licht.
Ja gut jetzt sind wir auch zusammen.
So.
Wo müssen wir lang? Da oben.
Fuck.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Viech?
Okay wir ballerns mal nicht weiter an.
Wie der Karsten immer nur am Zeug looten.
Oh ne Boltok hier.
Beste.
Hier gibt's auch noch was zu looten.
Collectibles.
Oh 3,33%
Juhu.
Ich hab jetzt deine Snap gelootet.
Ja gönn dir.
Okay wo geht's lang?
Dave pull sie mal.
Wenn man speedrunnt.
Da.
Checkpoint warte.
Ups.
Hier.
Ich bin schon durchgelaufen.
Bist du da?
Ah man kann diese roten Tester also anschließen.
Irgendjemand ist durch.
Irgendjemand ist durch
Boah.
zu zielen was haben wir liegen auch schneider schneider mini gar nicht
schreiber okay das kann man nach hinten gar nicht ich kann vor allem hier ich
kann mit dem ding nichts gescheit machen jetzt werden sie weggestellt darum oder
auch nicht ja weg weg stellen die lmc sagt über range
du sagst komm hier in die dora wird jetzt angestellt angestellt
muss man waffen wechseln ist total mit dem ding
mal ran
also im heller gegeben richtige heller
warte mal ich muss mal hier noch den nebenraum gestellt muss auch noch mal
lüften runde gibt's irgendwas kann man hier nicht runter hüpfen was ist das für
ein blöd
collectible collected weißt du wie geil das auf der 360 war wie diese diese
ganze achievement geschichte wir haben ja teilweise weiß doch wo dieses
komische avatar game da extra gekauft haben für achievements ausgegeben für
gs games wir haben damals leute so ein komisches was war das hier aber da der
elemente ja ja irgendwie so ist und so geht es und avatar games
ja irgendwie so ist und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es
und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es und so geht es
also passt ich zu diesem ersten game das hat das erste game gekauft weil dann
konnte man 1000 gamer score machen in den ersten zwei minuten
du musstest du musst jetzt einfach am start stehen bleiben und immer die
gleiche tasse drücken
welche schwierigkeitcellen wir
biết arerael
viau culpa
ich hab nur mal in der hälfte economic kannst du gesagt du gewinnst du bist ein
auf dem höchsten gespielt hat, ja.
Also außer des allerersten Gears.
Wir sind mittlerweile schlecht.
Wo müssen wir jetzt hin, Mann?
Dave, lass Dave pulsen.
Alter, wir sind so schlecht.
Oh, du kannst Dave da rein, rein, ähm,
schicken.
Du kannst Dave hier irgendwie reinschicken, glaube ich.
Da oben oder was?
Ach hier, gucke mal.
Wo denn?
Man muss aimen und dann muss man
Körbe X drücken.
Zack.
Verstehe.
Ich laufe irgendwie so ein bisschen
und sie lenke ich gerade mit dem Ding, oder?
Bin erstmal reingedasht.
Irgendwie,
I don't know.
Vielleicht haben sie die Steuerung
einfach ein bisschen anders gemacht.
Nee, es ist nicht die richtige.
Man kann ja anpassen.
Okay.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Zeug.
Blut.
Oh.
Sind die durchgelesen, was das ist?
Das war ein Comment vom Frosch.
Der hat geschrieben, aber Akele.
Kennst du denn noch den Frosch?
Was, welchen Frosch?
Da gab es doch auf YouTube den Typ,
Chat, kennt ihr den Frosch noch?
Das war,
der hat auf YouTube immer unter jedes,
unter jedes Video geschrieben,
aber Akele.
Oder aber Ekle.
Irgendwie sowas.
Jetzt habe ich dieses komische Ding.
Ja, ich wollte es.
Aber ich habe es weggeschmissen.
Guck mal, hier kann man bestimmt jetzt.
Ah.
Ups.
Was ist das?
Ist das so eine Flex, oder?
Ja, denn guck mal, jetzt ist das dort oben gestuckt.
I don't know.
Ach.
Okay, Dave, wo müssen wir hin?
Hier ist ein Safe.
Hier muss er hin, der Dave.
Dave, crack it open.
Dave ist praktisch, ne?
Einer ist mit dem Dave.
Ha?
Dave ist praktisch, was der alles kann.
Naja, aber Dave sagt irgendwie immer den Dave hier.
Ja, ich fände es auch viel, viel besser.
Du gehst hin, drückst E, reißt den Safe auf und gut ist.
Ich meine, jetzt müssen wir bestimmt wieder daven, oder?
Bestimmt.
Na klar, es ist ja immer nur daven.
Das ist.
Ich wette, mit dir der Roboter stirbt.
Weil, weil, die, die, die, die bauen den so auf, weißt du?
Alter, jetzt gebe ich den voll.
Ach so, wir müssen zusammen.
Gibst du dem Dick in die.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sagen darf auf Twitch.
Ich kenne nur noch die Leute, die beim 20.000-Abo-Special dabei waren.
Hier liegt viel Zeug rum.
Oh, hier, guck mal, eine Boomshot.
Die kannst du dir gönnen.
Ja, besser als der Hammerburst.
Du bist mit diesem fetten Ding da.
Ist das hier was?
Ist das was zum Werfen?
Ah, ne, das ist Boomshot-Ammo.
Und, und, und, und.
Guck mal, da sind doch welche, oder?
Da wird jetzt rein geboomshottet.
Pass mal auf.
Bah.
Lol.
Komm runter hier.
Jetzt schreckt.
Ich komme ja nicht runter.
Das Ziel ist echt komisch.
Oh, da ist auch noch jemand mit der Boomshot.
Moment, wie kommt man hier runter?
Ach, einfach runterlaufen.
Big Brain.
Der wird, der wird jetzt counter-boomshottet.
Ach, da sind uns noch drin.
Warum lebt der denn noch?
Alter, oh.
Au!
Alter, mein Aim.
Ich krieg nix geschissen auf der Xbox.
Jetzt aber.
Ich glaube, der hält einfach nur viel aus.
Hier siehst du den Lebensbalken hast du drüber.
Ja, ja.
Aber ich dachte eigentlich, früher sind die, auch die fettesten Gegner bei einem Boomshot-Treffer gesplattert.
Nein.
Das ist Granate voll in die Fresse.
Ich hab ein bisschen das Problem, dass ich manchmal nicht sehe, was jetzt hier Gegner
und was nie ist.
Oh, WST-Song.
Ach, guck mal, Dave macht noch was.
Der elektrisiert die Gegners.
Wir werden geschockt.
Zuniert die Waffe halt.
Bist du schon dran gewöhnt, Active zu reloaden?
Hm?
Bist du schon gewöhnt, so Active Reload zu machen und immer zur richtigen Zeit zu drücken?
Das kann ich noch ein bisschen, aber es...
Ist das zum meisten?
Das kann ich nur mit dem Nashorino.
Früher, ich weiß noch, wo ich Ultimate Edition gezockt hab, da konnte ich das sogar drücken, ohne hinzugucken.
Ich glaub, wir müssen die Eier erstmal kaputt machen, ne?
Da kommt bestimmt was raus, wenn wir die Eier nicht kaputt machen.
Früher haben die aber auch was gesagt.
Wie hast du denn, du, Active Reload getroffen?
Ja, ja.
Jetzt sagen die gar nichts mehr.
Da weißt du gar nicht, ne?
Du musst immer oben rechts in die Ecke gucken, das ist übelst dämlich.
Oh, bin ich dumm, Alter.
Wo geht's denn weiter?
Lass mal, Dave ping.
Nee, die sagen nix mehr.
Nee, die sagen, das ist dumm.
Aber wo geht's denn lang?
Ach, da.
Da muss man Dave hinschicken wieder.
Oder auch nicht.
Hast du?
Nö.
Aber ich glaube, wir können einfach irgendwie hin.
Na, guck mal da, da kann man...
Das ist...
Hä?
Big Brain.
Small Brain.
Zu klein.
Hier, warte mal.
Hier war da gerade so ein Y-Ding.
Echt?
Wo?
So.
Hä?
Kriegst du alles angezeigt, Jason Skidder?
Dann schick den einfach da rüber.
Nee, ist ja nicht so.
Dave ist der Einzige, der den Launch starten kann.
Vielleicht müssen wir...
Naja, wissen wir ja.
Vielleicht müssen wir da wieder rein.
Ich glaub, wir müssen wieder in den Raum zurück und dann Dave irgendwelche Dinger machen lassen.
Ja...
Gut.
Weil die anderen NPCs stehen da auch drinnen rum.
Hier, guck mal.
Hier.
Warum kann das eigentlich nur Dave machen? Warum kann ich da nicht draufdrücken?
Nee, das kann der machen.
Es ist alles deins.
Die Stimme vom Friseur ist wie vor neun Jahren.
Na, wir sind ja auch beide schon aus dem Stimmbruch gewesen, als wir YouTube angefangen haben, ne?
Wobei...
Manche sagen ja noch nie so richtig, ne?
Der Baird.
Hat der Friseur auch einen Twitch-Kanal, ja?
iFrisi.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen iFrisi, mit Y.
Aber normalerweise spielt er so komisches Asia-Grinder-Zeug.
Hä, was heißt komisch?
Ist doch...
Den ist voll gut.
Für die meisten Leute ist das komisch.
Ayaya!
Jetzt müssen wir... Jetzt sind wir wieder getrennt, oder?
Nee.
Sind wir nicht nebeneinander, ne?
Das war im Ersten übelst schwer auf schwer, ne?
Kennste? Wo man... Wo man diese Szenen... Wo man getrennt kämpfen musste und dann bei einer gestorben ist, war man down?
Alter, bei mir ist hier jemand schon wieder.
Was?
Bei der anderen Seite sind welche.
Ja, jedenfalls.
Ich... Ich wurde wieder seitlich getroffen.
Die waren übelst der Marke.
Weil ihr müsst Ausrufezeichen iFrisi machen, auch für alles Kleingestehen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man damit spielt, mit dem Teil. Ach so, okay.
Ach, so ging das ja in Gears. Du konntest ja hier so von Cover zu Cover stelzen, ne?
Ja.
Jetzt check ich's... Langsam check ich's wieder.
Ja, so ging das, genau.
Die Kontaktkurve ging nicht rüber mit dem Teil.
Das ist Dave. Dave kann das alles.
Nee. Geht nicht.
Lutsch, Dave.
Guck da, da kann man Dave schon hinschicken hier.
Du machst das schon mit dem Dave.
Dave fackelt die gerade ab.
Ach, da hinten sind noch welche.
Ich will sich auch von Lutsch getroffen werden.
Ja, wir müssen... Wir müssen noch die... Oh, fuck.
Wir müssen jetzt noch irgendwie die andere Raketenseite starten.
Wir müssen halt nur checken.
Ich hab jetzt X gedrückt, irgendwas hat's gemacht.
Da ist Dave, hat jetzt... Der hat jetzt den Robber dahin geschickt.
Ich glaube, über uns sind noch welche.
Nee, auf der anderen Seite ist noch einer.
Kann man den sägen?
Nee.
Oh, fuck, fuck.
Ich verrecke.
Ich hab... Ich wollte ihn sägen und das ging nicht.
Help.
Warte.
Alter, ich...
Wie der... Wie der rumslidet.
Ja, der wird gebasht.
Bei mir war es X.
Wo ist denn der... Ach, da hat's...
Erstmal, auf Ende des Games haben wir das übelste Xbox-Aim.
Und dann... Und dann spielen wir auf der Xbox Modern Warfare.
Wenn's rauskommt.
Ah, I don't know.
Äh...
Nee, ich hab mir noch so einen komischen Adapter gekauft, wo du Tastaturen schließen kannst.
Das ist eigentlich richtig... Richtig Cheat, wenn du so willst.
Ja.
So, okay.
Dave, wo geht's lang?
Da drüben wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Ah, nice.
Ich glaub, wir hätten die gar nicht killen müssen.
Wir hätten... Wir hätten die einfach... Die einfach die Rakete einschalten müssen.
Easy.
Braucht man irgendwie Muni?
Kann man jetzt hier hoch?
Nee.
Ah, hier.
Alter.
Der... Oh, der muss gebasht werden.
Glutsch-Bash.
Warte mal, warte mal. Bleib mal stehen.
Nee, vergessen.
Kann ich den sägen?
Nee, nee.
Nee.
Konnte man in den alten Teilen nicht mit B... Mit B die Säge anlassen, wenn man den Lancer draußen hatte?
Das wäre ja okay mit Muni.
Oh.
Ah, alles klar.
Hast... Du hast die Granate dran gesteckt.
Ja.
Bisschen Munitionsverschwendung.
Oh, nee, hier ist ne Shotgun.
Hier ist ne Shotgun.
Ich hab keinen Platz für ne Shotgun.
Ich seh die ganze Zeit über... Beim überlegen, ob ich wirklich mit rechts gerannt bin.
Mit A ist man immer gerannt.
Mit A ist man gerannt.
Oh.
Ich glaub, wir müssen uns verpissen.
Ich hab kein Platz für eine Shotgun.
Ich hab keine Chance.
Ja.
Oh.
Oh, ich noob.
Oh, oh, hast du mich grad gerannt?
Nee, aber gut.
Aber gut.
Sag mal, wo müssen wir hin?
Ach, gar nicht.
Einfach, einfach Zwischensequenz.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn einer sterben würde, kommt eine Zwischensequenz.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wir müssen jetzt Roleplayen.
Dave!
Das geht nicht.
Nein, Dave.
FAKE NEWS!
Ja, da hast du recht.
Nochmal.
Die Untertitel sind total dumm, da steht dann da
ROCKET BLAST.
Ja, ja, ich hab's gesehen.
Hast du auch Tattoos? Nee.
Ja, du? Ja.
Ich hab keine.
Dafür hast du jetzt ganz viele.
Ja.
Hab ich letztens gesehen im Schrieb. Du hast jetzt am Hals irgendwie noch, ne?
Warum guckt
der denn jetzt so, ähm,
disproved so irgendwie so?
Warum guckt der denn jetzt so, so, so,
als hätte er was angestellt?
Oh, es gibt GS!
Launched a rocket.
Wo noch mehr? Achso.
Hold, hold Knopf!
Wann kommt die Träne und die Rolex-Krone unterm Auge?
Achso!
Ach, das ist ne Rolex-Krone,
die er unterm Auge hat.
Ich hab mich immer gefragt, was der unterm Auge hat.
Wer?
A Montana Black.
Achso, ja, stimmt.
Das ist ne Rolex-Krone!
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich wusste nicht immer,
dass das ne Krone ist. Ich auch nicht!
Ich wusste gar nicht,
was, ich wusste nicht, was das ist.
Ich hab immer gedacht, dass das irgendwie
nen, nen Fleck.
Mutter mal, dran erinnern.
Ja, sowas.
Ja, ich hab,
ich hab das noch nie gezoomt gesehen.
Storytime.
Warum ist Markus eigentlich
so ein Spast geworden?
Das ist dann der Markus, oder?
Der Linke, klar!
Echt? Ja!
Der war früher nie so cool, oder?
Der war früher,
der war noch nie irgendwas.
Er zählte mal nie rum.
Das ist ein schlechtes Reaction,
Alter!
Wenn wir nicht streben würden, ne?
Ich glaub, wir würden die Zwischensequenz
skippen.
Ich wusste es!
Wir haben bis jetzt immer alles geskippt,
ey.
Durchgespielt und so.
Na ja, okay, alles klar.
Also, Leute, wir skippen
normalerweise immer Zwischensequenzen.
Ja.
Vor allem bei Gears.
Ich will jemanden wissen, was ich an meinem Hals
tätowiert habe, aber das sieht man nicht richtig.
Da gibt es keine Zeit.
Der hat mich automatisch an die alten angehoben.
Oh, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das jetzt machen soll.
Oh, danke, Iris.
Deine Vokal-Sentimente sind nicht mit deinen Worten
in der Literatur einmenschlich.
Bitte stopp das Reden!
Also, ich kann immer noch nicht
die andere Brille finden, wie der alte.
Auf der anderen Seite
habe ich einen AI-Modus gegründet,
der Sarcastik versteht.
Also Leute, ihr könnt es ja mal vergleichen, ne?
Der Fabian hat ja Bert als Avatar auf Twitch.
Das sieht sich überhaupt nicht ähnlich.
Gut, die ist halt alt, ne?
Jetzt älter.
Aber du siehst auch nicht, wenn du älter wirst,
du siehst überhaupt nicht mehr aus wie du.
Nee, doch. Na klar, ne?
Ja, ja.
Und echt schon.
Wirklich?
Sieht nicht ähnlich aus.
Naja.
Okay, der Chat sagt ja auch, das ist Bert.
Markus sieht...
Ja, Markus sieht noch aus wie...
Markus sieht noch so aus wie früher, ja.
Ich geh mal pissen, by the way.
Mach mal.
So nice ist das grad nicht.
YouTube ist Vorstory, ja.
Wir machen das, wir skippen ab der nächsten Karte,
die wird als...
Skippt, ah.
Ah, das ist geskippt.
Oh, okay, weiter.
Boah, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das fertig gepingelt habe.
Jetzt kann ich mal wieder seit irgendwie zwei Stunden
mal in den Chat gucken.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ähm, ja, jede Menge.
Hast du für angehende Freesies in FFM-Tipps?
Äh, das muss man eigentlich mal bei anderen...
mit anderen Streben beschwätzen.
Ich glaub da vor allem,
dann ist der wieder da.
Wie der Chat versucht, der Freesie
den Channel rauszufinden, ne?
Falls wir ein Mod da haben,
wir können theoretisch auch noch ein...
ein zweites Command dafür machen.
Hab ich Subs über?
Ja.
Subs.
Big Brain-Subs.
Ich kann mich nochmal einloggen bei Steamlabs.
Oh, geht weiter, oder was?
Jaja, ich hab gerade mal kurz Pause gemacht.
Ich muss gucken, ob ich Subs übersehen hab.
Ja, hab ich, ich hab einen Sub.
The Real Cracks hab ich übersehen,
dankeschön.
Und Variety hab ich auch übersehen.
Äh, Rip?
Ja.
Jutsch.
Okay, weiter, weiter geht's.
Ja.
Nice.
I'm gonna take this.
Okay.
Dave, ping.
Also, ich hab schon gesagt,
ab nächsten Zwischensequenz
skippen wir einfach alles.
Nee.
Hä?
Komm.
Upgrade.
Den checken wir wieder.
Ah, jetzt müssen wir den Roboter zusammensetzen,
oder was?
Den da?
Hä?
Ach, hier gibt's Zeug.
Guck mal da.
Das ist der Bärt.
Da in der Mitte, ne?
So mit dem, mit dem,
mit den Gläsern auf dem Kopf.
Okay, was muss man machen?
Hier oben, da, da ist was.
Bashen.
Ja, wir können ja nur bashen.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Deswegen sacken wir auch immer so basis-damage-Story-Sequenzen.
Jetzt haben wir New Ability.
Oh, wir haben Flash.
Aha, okay.
Kannste skillen.
Skillen?
Die Mannheit?
Ach, Leute, warum braucht denn jedes Game
jetzt mittlerweile so ein Kack-Skilltree, Alter?
Was ist das denn?
Ich glaube, das ist einfach für den, für den Dave.
Ach, das ist für den Dave, okay.
Du musst, glaube ich, auswählen, oder?
Open Jack-Menü.
Aber ich darf nichts machen.
Aber das ist jetzt Jack und nicht mal Dave.
Ach so, doch nicht, warte mal.
Ach so.
Dave wurde Upgraded und heißt jetzt Jack.
Okay, Assaults.
Passives.
Du musst auswählen, oder?
Ja, ja, doch.
Also, wir können Hells upgraden, Stelz, oder...
Stelz, Scheiße, Hells.
Stun, Stun, Enemy Stun, das ist gut.
Das Upgrade war.
Install an Equipment.
So, how do we use it?
I'll show you.
Ich habe mich jetzt so an Dave gewöhnt.
Ich will Dave wieder, ich will nicht Jack.
Okay, grab a weapon and get into cover.
Then we'll start the test.
Cover.
Weapon?
Moment, wo, wo ist Weapon?
Ach, hier, ganz viele Weapons.
Huge Weapons.
Ja.
Ein Enser, Alter.
Mit Shotgun, ne?
Iris, excavate Alpha 331.
Ja.
Oh, was denn das?
Guck mal, das ist was Neues.
Schneiber, Schneiber ist das ja.
So, say you got a target that seems awfully comfortable behind cover.
Jacks Flash Ability fixes that.
Aim at the DB and activate it.
See what happens.
Also, LT.
Guck mal, das ist so ein Elektroschock-Waffe hier.
LT und Hübschelon.
Flash.
Hallo?
Ach so, mach schon.
Und jetzt kann man bashen.
Ah.
F4.
Hm, ist ja eigentlich nicht so.
Wurde nicht auch angezeigt, dass du...
Iris, excavate Alpha 332.
Wurde nicht auch angezeigt, dass du aktiv Reload hast und mehr Damage?
Jacks gotta reroute power between Flashes.
Ja, früher war das so.
Hit him again.
Ich darf den hier nicht erschießen.
Also, wir müssen die jetzt wieder flashen.
Wir müssen den Dave flashen lassen, Alter.
So, mach.
Nice.
Weg.
Nice work.
Ja.
Still free to ref against anyone.
Der Eichler.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die Commands nicht funktionieren.
Was?
Would you like to run another test?
No.
Test sequence complete.
No, I will bash.
Ja, Eax, die Grafik ist relativ gut im Vergleich zum alten.
Ich glaube aber, auf der X-Bone war das schon nicht schlecht.
Oder?
Gears 4 war da auch nicht bad.
Gears 4?
War Gears 4 schon auf der X-Bone?
Nee, Judgment war auf der One, oder?
Warte mal, nee.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Judgment auf der alten X-Bone.
Das war das letzte auf der One.
Judgment war übelst eulig.
Ich glaube, du musst zurücklegen, oder, Rafa?
Ja.
Nee, guck mal, auf der X-Bone gibt es doch schon drei Gears-Teile.
Was?
Ja, Ultimate Edition.
Ach, stimmt.
Ja, die haben das ja neu released.
Gears 4 und...
Ja, ja, stimmt, stimmt, Ultimate Edition.
Da habe ich überhaupt nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, es gibt ja die alten Dinger auch.
Good.
Now I can get back to work.
Was Danon sagen will, ist, dass er mehr wichtige Dinge zu tun hat.
Danke, Iris.
Blutigkeit ist eines von Iris' größten...
Okay, Bär.
Wir sind in Kontakt.
Nice.
C-U-Bär.
Okay, Jungs, los geht's.
Keine Sorgen.
Macht euer...
Ding.
Cuckoo-Bär.
Was ist denn der?
Was ist denn mit dem los?
Jetzt kommt der Coal Train.
Jetzt kommt der Coal Train, genau.
Hey, Fuzz.
Hey, das ist Fuzz.
Was ist das?
Brilliant.
We can't all be off on some secret mission.
Oh, yeah?
How'd you hear about that?
Der Coal Train, das merkt man sich so im Blödsinn, ne?
Ja, okay.
Well, look.
We'll just leave you to the very important work.
Punching machines.
And sparring.
Hang on a second, shitstick.
Shitstick?
Del, there is...
I don't know.
Maybe a stick made out of shit?
Or a stick used to stir up shit.
Alright, fuck off.
How about we make this interesting?
You and me spar right now.
And how exactly is beating you interesting?
Oh, musst du jetzt boxen?
Yes or no.
Bitte, nee, ich will einfach nur...
Ich will bashen, ja.
Ich will einfach nur irgendwelche Locusts killen.
Man.
Then again, maybe not.
Hilarious.
Are you in or not?
Oh, I'm in.
Gibt's Carmine eigentlich noch?
Der stirbt bestimmt wieder.
Bam.
Oh nee, ich glaube, ich muss echt boxen mit dem Typ jetzt.
Echt?
Ach nee, nee, ist Zwischensequenz.
Ist Zwischensequenz.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich komme gerade bei dir.
Wie sieht's eigentlich aus deiner Sicht aus?
Wie sieht was aus?
Du siehst die gleiche Zwischensequenz, oder?
Nur.
Okay.
Genau das gleiche.
Ah, gut.
Weiter bashen.
Mit Bart siehst du aus wie 40 ohne 20.
Hier gibt's Achievement Grab.
Bashen.
Gönn dir.
Oh, eine Notice.
Sieben, sieben, sieben.
Sieben.
Ich hab's nicht gelesen.
Ich hab's direkt weggeklickt.
Oh, hier, guck mal.
Hier kann man Muscles bilden.
Gains?
Was?
Hier kann man ja boxen.
Das sind Gains machen.
Wo?
Das ist gut, dass ich heute nicht ins Gym gegangen bin.
Hier ist ja einsam.
Hier kann man boxen.
Kannst den Knopf drücken, ja.
Kann man da irgendwas machen?
Oh, wie viel Kilo gibt's denn hier?
25?
Weil, es ist alles das Gleiche.
Fünf Kilo.
Fünf?
Das krieg ja sogar ich hin.
Die Typen, die Typen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Typen übelste Muskelwerke hier.
25.
Fünf Kilo.
25 ist das Höchste.
Aber guck dir mal das Ding an.
Das Ding wiegt im Leben mehr als fünf Kilo.
Und das ist so ein komplettes Metallding.
Ja.
Riesenfettes Metallding, ey.
So groß wie der Arm.
Guck mal, das ist so groß wie der Arm.
Das Ding ist so groß wie der Arm von dem Dude.
Aber fünf Kilo.
Läuft bei denen auf jeden Fall.
Läuft, ja.
So, bashen, Alter.
Wo geht's weiter?
Das ist nicht das erste Gears auf dem PC.
Es gab Gears 1.
Das erste gab's schon auf dem PC.
Genau.
Und die vier gab's nie für den PC?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich schon.
Wahrscheinlich Crossplay.
Oder nicht Crossplay.
Also diese Windows Store Geschichte.
Creating.
Oh, guck mal.
Ah.
Was mach ich denn jetzt?
Jetzt musst du auswählen, ja.
Was ist denn das nächste unter...
Was kann man da jetzt nachstunnen?
Kannst du auch mehr...
Komm, nenn mal mehr HP.
Mehr HP ist bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
So zumindest das erste Level mehr HP.
Hm.
Ja, HP ist immer gut.
Ja.
Ist ja mehr GS.
Easy.
Soll ich den auch noch mal upgraden jetzt, oder was?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee.
Ich dachte das auch erst, aber das ist nicht so.
Da geht immer noch einer.
Guck mal, hier sind wir im Locker Room.
Wo bist du?
Hier ist noch ein Upgrade.
Guck mal, was ich alles finde, du.
Irgendwie hab ich...
Check ich überhaupt nicht.
Manchmal nennt man mich rumschnell.
Drück einfach hier LMB oder was das ist.
Ich seh dich.
Du bist...
Ach so.
Halt mal links oben gedrückt.
Da siehst du immer, wo die Leute sind.
Huge.
Die sind auch im...
Ja, ach.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
War das bei den alten Teilen auch schon so?
Ja.
Kann ich auch noch mal dran erinnern.
Lol.
Alter, geh mal hier her, Max.
Hm?
Hast du hier so ne Lupe?
Nee.
Hier wird grad irgendwas gefaselt.
Vielleicht ist das dein.
Vielleicht ist das dein Schrank.
Kann auch sein.
Hier liegt ne Banane.
Die ist aber hässlich gefärbt.
Guck mal, sieht so unecht aus.
Die sieht verschimmelt aus.
Aber die ist leicht traurig.
Ja, wo die wohl überall war?
Hier hab ich ne Lupe jetzt.
Okay, das ist einfach nur Lore.
Könnte sein, dass das irgendwie unterschiedliche Characters, unterschiedliche...
Aktionen, ja.
Kann schon sein.
Aber das bringt hier alles nix.
Das ist...
Einfach nur zum nett anschauen.
Da gibt's kein GS für.
Guck mal, jetzt ist Sniper hier.
Sniper?
Sniper end.
Aber geht nicht.
Gut, weiter.
Bashen.
Gut, bash.
Auf.
Go, go, go.
Kann ich jetzt nicht das Grill übernehmen?
Früher ging das irgendwie, dass man Characters übernehmen konnte.
Ja, spiel mal das Grill.
Oder die Waffen davon.
Nee, kann nicht.
Ich glaube, hier ist bestimmt Fix.
Weil, doch, das muss Fix sein.
Weil du konntest doch im Startbildschirm auch auswählen...
Also nicht auswählen, wen du spielen willst.
Sondern man musste einfach sagen, an Slot 2...
Ja gut, du konntest Dave spielen, ne?
Stimmt, du hattest theoretisch Dave spielen können.
Aber da wäre ich ja jetzt down.
Da wärst du weg.
Hier, ich mach mal auf.
Wir gehen jetzt bashen.
Jetzt.
Twitch bash.
John Canali, drei.
Twitch, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Kohlbraten, danke, Twitch Prime.
Not, not nice.
Well, I'll remind you, your wife refused the idea of bringing the hammer back online.
Der Hammer.
I would have thought you'd respect Anyas wishes.
Ey, das ist Anya, die gab's im ersten Teil.
Das war die im Heli.
Die ist nicht mehr geil, ne?
Anya war ein nices Grill.
Hä, war die aber nie blond?
Doch.
Anya ist blond gewesen.
Das ist jetzt ne richtige Milf, du.
Das ist nicht Anya.
Das auf dem Bild ist Anya gewesen.
Ach so.
Ach, das ist Jin.
Ich seh's grade, hä?
Sieht ja bissl asiatisch aus.
I honor Anya.
Anya, I loved.
I don't care if you believe me.
When my program was in its infancy, she came to me.
She volunteered.
Both times she volunteered.
Ach, da ist sie, guck mal.
Hot Grill?
Do you know how many children are alive today thanks to her?
Ja, Anya war ein nices Grill, war Anya.
She should be better than you.
Mit so nem Gears-Anzug.
The people need her inspiration.
Your inspiration was my wife.
Ich muss, wie im Real Life, muss man immer auf diese Flecken gucken, ja?
Musst du auch immer auf diesen Fleck gucken, bei der das stammt?
Ich hab grad nicht hingeguckt, ich hab im Chat geguckt.
Was?
Zwischensequenz.
Guck mal da, Achtung, über der Augenbraue.
Stimmt, ja.
Jetzt hab ich's gesehen, jetzt kann ich mal weggucken.
I can explain.
Ja, jetzt siehst du's jedes Mal.
Explain how launching a Hammer of Dawn's satellite doesn't...
Der Hammer der Morgenröte ist das jetzt.
Same page, huh?
Haben sie doch immer gesagt.
Lieutenant, the Hammer of Dawn has taken more cog lives than most of the armies we've opposed.
Your father knows this as well as anyone.
It's not the weapons I don't trust in the First Minister.
It's the people who use them.
Alter Bärschen.
Ich hol mir mal schnell was zu trinken.
Das ist eh ewig Zwischensequenz.
Ah.
That'll be a report on the evacuation of Settlement 2.
Settlement 2 is being evacuated? Why?
There's been activity in the nearby burial site.
Chief Carmine, report.
Please, slow down.
Wie lange sind die Zwischenzeit?
Es läuft ja immer noch.
Oh, jetzt go.
Do it, do it. Auf geht's.
Wo ist mein Controller? Hier, wir doen's jetzt.
Oh, Akt 1, Chapter 3, let's go.
Echt?
Weißt du noch früher, wo ich immer so den Tick hatte, meinen Controller zu schlagen?
Das war richtig dumm, oder?
Das war richtig dumm.
Wo ich immer da gesessen hab.
Ja, genau.
Du hast es anders gemacht.
Das geht mit dem Controller nicht mehr.
Der hat keine Batterie und kein Play-to-Play-and-Charge-Kit.
Mir ist ja das Play-and-Charge-Kit immer abgefallen.
Das kennt er doch noch, oder?
Stimmt.
Ist das der Coal Train gewesen jetzt?
Fuck, ich weiß gar nicht, was hier abgeht.
Ich brauch den Coal Train.
Könnt ihr nicht mal normal irgendwo landen, immer stützbar sein?
Ja, aber in jedem Teil, ne?
Ja.
Und das 20 Mal im Game.
Und dann 5 Minuten Cutscene.
Alter, was sind das für welche?
Lol.
Aufwäschen.
Oh, fuck, Alter, ich bin schon fast down.
Fuck.
Ach, das ist echter Coal.
Der echte Coal Train ist das hier.
Alter.
Steck hier jetzt doch einfach mal an.
Ich leg hier, ich leg hier.
Ich kann nur Pistole schießen.
Oh.
Wo bist denn du?
Alter, wir sind getrennt.
Kann das sein?
Warte mal, wo bist denn du?
Na?
Alter, das wird er wieder nicht.
Ach, du musst mich, glaub ich, retten.
Wie kann das sein?
Oh, nee.
Digga.
Ich warte hier einfach, bis die Hochrichter jetzt Coal und Digga alles.
Die bashen mich aber mit der Zeit hier unten.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich bin Meistersäger.
Oder, warte mal.
Hier, die Nasher. Let's go.
Oh, hier ist ein Boss am Start jetzt.
Das ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Kann ich hier irgendwie raus?
Ja.
Okay, ich glaub, ich hab alles gebasht.
Ich glaub, ich hab alles gebasht.
Kann nur sein, dass du irgendwas mit Dave machen musst.
Guck mal, hier ist der Dave Arena.
Ich glaub, du musst mich retten, weil ich kann nichts machen.
Warte mal.
Ich leg...
Ach, das kann doch sein, dass ich hier runter muss.
Ich leg hier unten irgendwie eingeklemmt rum.
Das Aim.
So schlecht war das Aim grad gar nicht.
Ich hab die alle gebasht.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Bashen, Alter.
Was denn, ey?
Du bist da oben.
Ah, guck mal. Hier.
Ja, ich hab's. Das... Ah, okay.
Ist ja dumm gemacht.
Da kommt er.
Oh, das seht ihr ja. Da ist er.
Der Frasier. Der rettet uns jetzt.
Oh, nee. Nein!
Ja, warte mal. Nee, das geht schon.
Der Typ. Der Typ.
Der Cole rettet dich jetzt.
Ah, alles klar.
Ey, stell dir mal vor, du spielst das auf Insane.
Ja, ist direkt RIP.
Du musst mit dem Maus und Tastatur spielen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Ich mach hier einfach MAB.
Das ist gut.
Da. Da sind sie.
Oh, hier ist ein Spielautomat.
Sorry, Max, aber keine Zeit.
Erst mal Achievements machen, ne?
Erst mal Gamerscore.
Ach. So, wo bist du jetzt?
Ah, hier.
Andere Richtung.
Warte, warte.
Au. Oh.
Oh, du bist unnormal.
Hä?
Bin ich down? Ach.
Bin ich down?
Nee. Nee.
Dachte schon, ja.
Yitz.
Hä? Wtf? Ich hab dich gar nicht gesehen, man.
Ich lag die ganze Zeit unter dem Ding.
Oh, weiter, Baer.
Ja gut.
Oh, Carmine ist auch am Start.
Ja, dann...
Aber irgendwie hat man wenig Muni.
Trotz dass es nicht so ein hoher Schwierigkeitsgrad ist, ne?
Ja, die fressen halt auch.
Guck mal, hier liegt wieder Start, warte.
Zack.
Hier lag Muni.
Man kann übrigens auch Muni teilen, hab ich gesehen, wenn man ran geht und X drückt.
Hier ist wieder Dave Upgrade.
Also man kann irgendwie Munition teilen.
Ich hab zwei so ne Dinger, was kann man nochmal?
Was ist denn das hier?
Stelz ist kacke, oder?
Stelz brauchen wir nicht, gehst Stelzen.
Also wenn wir Stelzen, bei uns ist Stelzen geradeaus draufrennen und bashen.
Vorher ist Tragfähigkeit wahrscheinlich, um Waffen zu grabben.
Aber ich kann eh nix upgraden.
Ach, warte mal, doch.
Wir können doch eins upgraden, oder?
Haben wir nicht?
Doch, wir haben...
Für zwei Points gibt's nix, oder?
Zwei Components.
Ah, hier.
Ach, ne, stimmt.
Hast recht, ja.
Ne, drei, eins, das haben wir schon.
Ach ja, ich seh's.
Okay, ne, können wir eh nicht.
Ja.
Nicht.
Ich will den Enforcer nicht.
Okay, wo geht's lang?
Recht.
Ah, hier ist schon mal Muni, das ist schon mal gut.
Wo geht's lang?
Ich denke mal, wir müssen einfach...
Ne, hier kommen wir her.
So, hier muss man wieder durch, dieses Teil.
Oh, wieder Dave rumschicken.
Ne, ne.
Einfach X drücken.
Wo bist denn du?
Da drüben.
Ach, da.
Das hab ich...
Das ist übel sinnlos.
Das ist auch so ne Stelle.
Aber hier, eintreten, bashen.
Oh, was war das?
Hä?
Erstmal Entdeckung.
Da drunter.
Oh, fuck.
Wo ist der Tisch?
Alter, krasses Aimer.
Was ist das eigentlich für ne komische Kackwaffe, die ich da hab?
Der Enforcer.
Ist das irgendwie ne Pistole?
Achtung, jetzt.
Wo ist meine...
Wo ist meine Granate?
Hinter dir.
Oder bist du das da vorne?
Fuck.
Okay, ich hol dich.
Nice.
Hast du es gesägt, oder was ist der da?
Nein, das war...
Das war der...
Wie...
Wie kann man sägen an denen?
Früher konnte man da einfach...
B dran drücken.
Lange...
Also, ich weiß nicht, welche Taste das ist, aber...
Lange die Reload-Taste drücken.
Der wird X oder so.
Oh, ne.
Hammerwürste will ich nicht.
RIP.
Ja, was haben wir denn hier?
Ah, hier ist Intel.
Ah, ne, Bob, nicht Bob.
Dave Upgrades euch.
Ich muss mich unbedingt mal in Ultimate Edition einloggen und gucken, wie meine Steuerung war.
Es fühlt sich alles so falsch an.
Ich glaube, hier soll man nicht lang.
Ah, hier, guck mal, hier kann man rüberjumpen.
Okay, ich komme hoch.
Ja, langsam kriegt man die Steuerung wieder ein bisschen hin.
So, hier müssen wir aufstelzen.
Du musst mit mir aufmachen.
Haken wir den hier ernst, oder?
Was? Hä?
Wir haben gerade aufgemacht.
Ich dachte eigentlich auch, die springen jetzt dagegen oder treten dagegen oder so.
Und einfach raufgeschoben, das passt überhaupt nicht, ne?
Und wir bashen nicht so viel gelassen.
Ja, aber...
Guck mal, hier ist Carmine am Start.
Mit Helm.
Oh, du bist natürlich da, oder?
Ich bin da, also ich komme.
Ich hatte gerade noch ein Upgrade eingesammelt.
Für Dave Reno.
Oh, das ist gar nichts zum Bashen.
Gar nichts zum Bashen hier.
Warum?
Moment, warte mal, ich will den Enforcer nicht.
Ich will den Lancer.
Alter.
Oh.
So ist das gut.
Okay.
Wo geht es weiter?
Fick das Bike hier.
Lass mal pulsen, dann sehen wir, wo es weiter geht.
Wahrscheinlich einfach hier durch, oder?
Guck mal hier.
Ah, das ist wieder sowas, wo man drücken muss, ja.
Schreckt.
Never mind, Control.
Okay.
Jetzt ist es da.
Wie Lizzy.
Wie auch immer Lizzy ist.
Muss eine ganz coole sein.
Einer ist das Grill.
Ob es ein hottes Grill ist, wissen wir noch nicht.
Ah, okay.
Dann sieht er recht gut aus.
Der hat viel Halt.
Wie viel Halt hat der genau?
Übelst viel.
Ich werde den Shotgun den Tod.
Aber die Löwen, die die Löwen...
Die machen übelst Damage, da kann man nicht einfach ran...
Ne, die kann man ran, weil die auch nicht so splattern.
Außerdem aus dem Ziel da ganz merkwürdige Ecken, wenn man auf die Gegner zielt.
Komisch.
Aber ich glaube, das liegt einfach an mir.
Komm mal zu euch.
Ich glaube, das mit der Munition liegt daran, weil hier überall Munition rumliegt.
Und die wollen, dass man rumläuft und Munition aufhebt.
Und ich camp die in den ersten Tiers.
Hey, ich war jetzt hier Multiplayer, so.
Weil in den ersten Tiers hast du ja im Endeffekt hinter irgendeiner Deckung gesessen und nichts gemacht die ganze Zeit.
Schnibber!
Schleipsohr!
Weg, Schleiber!
Hier.
Alter, hier ist noch einer mit dem...
Oh, knapp.
Was ist denn das?
Oh, hier, Huge.
Hier.
Das Ding ist ja nice.
Oh, der schießt hinaus, richtig nice.
Ich muss weg!
Oh, ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Der Coal macht schon.
Oh, ein Schleiber auf mir, drop eh.
Wo ist der Dude?
Oh, jetzt wird er geschletzelt.
Geisterdown.
Lebst du noch?
Ja.
So, jetzt hab ich das Teil.
Das Ding ist übelst OP!
Wo denn eigentlich? Über uns, über uns da einer!
Okay, einer!
Regroupen!
Hat er gerade gesagt?
Panzer?
Au, au, au, au, au!
Haben die auf Mittel schon immer
so viel Damage gemacht?
Ne!
Ist einfach nicht schlecht!
Ne, ich glaube,
man muss mehr rumstelzen.
Ja, ich glaube, man muss mehr rumrollen.
Wir stelzen einfach weiter rum.
Ist das Vieh hier irgendwo?
Ne, ich hab hier!
Ach, das ist so ein Bossvieh, ich das helfe hier
übertrieben viel aus.
Don't get too close.
Naja, ich muss abhauen.
Ich will nicht zu close getten.
Ich hab keine Muni mehr!
Der schießt doch irgendwas da drüben.
Jetzt soll ich aufheben, der Enforcer.
Oh, jetzt hat's zerrissen.
GG.
Okay, thank you very much!
Also, meiner Meinung nach,
okay, kann so sein, dass wir sacken, aber...
Also, wir treffen auf jeden Fall schlecht.
...viel schwerer als sonst.
Kommt mir aber insgesamt auch so vor.
Ja.
Lohnt sich gar nicht mehr, mit den Dings reinzugehen irgendwie.
Boah, was ist das hier?
Die sind im Schacht.
Die sind übertrieben, das...
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Wo?
Die sind hier drüben, aber ich hab's schon.
Was denn?
Ja.
Ja, ne, wo geht's lang?
Ähm...
Wir müssen da ins Auto irgendwie, oder?
Ja, wo ist das Auto?
Ja.
Ah, Fahrstelz.
Vor uns war hier irgendein Zeichen.
Ja, dass wir uns da sammeln sollen.
Aber wir haben uns ja schon gesammelt.
Stimmt.
Ach hier, was ist denn mit LT?
Wir rennen jetzt einfach mal hier die Straße weiter und gucken.
Da bist du, okay.
Und, geht's da hinten weiter?
Warum nicht auf PC,
dass da Fabian Multiplayer spielen kann?
Irgendwann mal.
Hier hinten geht's, glaub ich, weiter.
Aber es kann doch nicht so sein, dass das so kompliziert gemacht ist,
wo es weitergeht.
Wobei ich mich frage,
ob ich überhaupt noch Multiplayer fähig bin.
Da musst du noch 10 Wochen üben, ey.
Vielleicht muss man einfach durch irgendein Haus durch, oder so.
Hier, guck mal.
Hier, wird aufgesägt.
Ach lol, guck mal.
Wenn du dieses Ding machst, siehst du auch, wie du weiter musst.
Dieses hier, wo die Leute sind.
Wird dir angezeigt.
Mit so einer Core-Marke.
Eine Cocktag?
Ja.
Dafür, dass der Max mit dem Friseur streamt, schauen sie viel zu wenig zu.
Ja, das ist Gears.
Gears ist auch langweilig zu gucken.
Also zum Zugucken ist Gears übelst langweilig.
enabling
leuchtenden Dinger gekämpft hast, die dann explodiert sind und auch rumgeflogen sind und so.
Mh, stimmt schon.
Das war nervig.
Das ging mir voll auf den Sack, der Dreier.
Das hier alles glaubt, es war der Dreier.
Oder der Vierer.
Der Coal Train, da ist er.
The Real.
Der ist komischerweise nigger, Alter.
Der sieht genauso aus wie vorher.
Das ist leid.
Das geht aber nicht.
Na doch, das könnte sogar...
Also...
Ich kann das nicht.
Ich glaube, man kann wieder richtig krass leiden.
Also wenn man es drauf hätte.
Diesmal kann man sich direkt noch kürzer abstoßen.
Da kommt was gekrabbelt.
Leute, hier gab es was zum...
Aufheben.
Collect.
Gamer Score.
Oh, nice.
Cocktag.
Hier kann er zum Beispiel gar nicht ran.
Hier muss man wieder durchstelzen.
Bist du da?
Ich warte, bis er da ist.
Nee, bin da.
Bin hinter dir.
Die Subtitel.
Music intensifies.
Solange nicht...
Ah, ja, ja.
Intensifies ist.
Hä, ja.
Oh, ja.
Ui.
Oh, wow.
Ich glaube, du Dinger musst noch aus der Hüfte bashen.
Geht besser als Aim.
Also mein Aim geht generell schlecht gerade.
Ich glaube, aus der Hüfte ist es einfacher.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich kann gar nicht gucken.
Äh, Allah.
Alea.
Fuck.
Carmine ist am Start.
Woher jetzt rein?
Warte mal ganz kurz.
So, genau.
Hä, der Cole ist hier drin.
Wie komme ich hier rein?
Warte mal.
Oh, drin.
Nee, ich bin auf der anderen Seite.
Omega Null.
Ich will rüberhüpfen.
Sag bloß, wir sind jetzt getrappt.
Wir blockieren uns gegenseitig.
Nee, nee.
Blockieren uns gegenseitig.
Wieso kommt das Game erst Montag raus und nicht heute am Freitag?
Weil du kein Xbox Premium-Sonstwas-Pass hast.
Kauf dir einfach für einen Euro.
Du kannst übelst Geld sparen.
Du musst dir einfach...
Ich habe aber auch keinen, ne?
Ja.
Und ich kann es zocken.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Aber es kann nur sein, dass es wegen der Ultimate Edition...
Komisch, ja.
Zumindest, du kannst dir ein Xbox Ultimate Game Pass kaufen.
Kostet einen Euro für einen Monat.
Und da ist das Game dabei.
Kannst du runterladen, Kampagne spielen und den Game Pass einfach canceln.
Natürlich, wenn du Multiplayer spielen willst, längere Sicht ist das nix.
Weil das Game ist weg nach einem Monat.
Aber für einen Euro ist okay.
Ja, dann müsstest du es dir nochmal kaufen, ne?
So ungefähr.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau.
Aber wahrscheinlich, was sonst, ja.
Irgendwie habe ich auch gelesen, dass man in der Kampagne dieses Wackeln ausstellen kann beim Rennen.
Das ist doch was für dich, Max.
Okay, nö, es stört mich diesmal gar nicht so.
Solange das Bild nicht tiert, ist alles gut.
Wie bei Second.
Oh, das hat so krass getiert.
Ich konnte es nicht spielen.
Ich muss ja wieder zu zweit.
Jetzt, so sollte man das aufmachen.
Weil andere haben es übelst low-bock-mäßig aufgeschiebt, ne?
So.
Gar nicht Gear-Style aus.
Kannst du dich noch an Army of Two erinnern?
Wo sie auch jedes Mal diese Türen so übelst stylisch aufgemacht haben?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Huge Aiming.
So knall, da haben wir uns immer aufgeregt.
Aber ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern, oder was?
Nee, ich habe gar keine Schocker mehr.
Dass sie die Türen so komisch aufgemacht haben.
Moment.
Ich meine, der Jackie, der holt mir jetzt irgendwas.
Ah, jetzt hier.
Ah, okay.
Moment.
Nate.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Damn.
Okay, was ist da oben los?
Moment, da muss ich noch mal eine Granate reinhauen.
Ah, du auch.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, das erste ist tot.
Das erste ist nicht so sauer.
Au, au, au, au.
Sägen, sägen.
Wie machen die das mit dem Sägen?
Ich will ihn auch sägen.
Früher war es B.
Das ist jetzt A.
Und was ist Sägen?
X.
Lange X.
Aber nur, wenn du am Gegner dran stehst, ne?
Oh ja.
Kein Fall.
Ich fahr mal in Ordentliche, oder?
Hier ist ein Schreiber.
Hier ist ein Overkill.
Wo?
Ja, das ist ein Schreiber.
Geil.
Schreiber ist ja weg.
Ist ja nicht so, dass ich KLA habe, aber...
Na, jetzt ist es geschnippt.
Da ist ein Schreiber.
Lanzer GL gibt's jetzt.
The Grenade Launcher.
Ja, den hab ich hingekriegt.
Der hat noch vier Schuss.
Ah, nice.
Die spasten.
Ist recht.
Ach, die sind hinter...
Warte, wo?
Wo?
Unten.
Hinter uns.
Da.
Damn.
Oh, lol.
Huge Nade.
Alter, das ist nice.
Endlich mal eine coole neue Waffe.
Jawohl.
Schreckt.
Sind wir tot?
Nö.
Aber die gleich.
Ich glaub, man muss ein bisschen vor dem schießen, dass es ihn trifft, wenn er weiterläuft.
Genau.
Oh, das wird ein Boss, der drei Milliarden Dinge aushält.
Hast du noch deinen Longshot?
Kannst du den Schleim sein?
Ja.
Ich hab schon, es passiert immer drauf.
Ja, die halten richtig viel aus.
Also, ich hab ... Also tot bin ich jetzt.
Von links kommt was.
Oh, hier, von hier kann man das nicht so gehandelt übernehmen.
Ich hab keine ... Ich hab keine populations.
Das guitars nicht.
Was, shoot,我不知道.
Weg sentimental.
Rechts von uns.
Oh, was geht jetzt ab?
Wir sind links von uns, Valcarix, sag mal Bescheid.
Ja, bei mir sind welche hier.
bei mir sind wir jetzt hier.
Ich würde hier rechts irgendwann bekommen.
Wir werden jetzt im Schreck. Oh, fuck!
Ich habe mich nicht rechtzeitig gedockt.
THX. Aber hier, Dave macht das.
Dave, Dave.
Alter! Gibt's doch nicht.
Ich bin wieder da.
Fuck! Ich hab dich.
Nein, ich hab dich nicht!
Jetzt musst du mich hochheben.
Hinter dir.
Wie die letzten Menschen, ey.
Ich kann aber nur...
Huge Aim.
Okay, das war klinger.
Gute Idee.
Massive Aim.
Wollen wir mal einen Nachschub?
Kann man noch einen Granaten-Nachschub vielleicht?
Ne, Granaten haben wir nicht mehr.
Ich will sägen, man.
Ich säge den jetzt. Jawoll!
Ey, die halten sich gegen das Auto.
Ich muss die Shotgun.
Oh, die splattern wirklich nicht mehr.
Was ist das denn?
Ey, ich säge hier einfach nur alle.
Haha, ich seh's.
Jetzt.
Ich seh dich jetzt.
Oh, das ist ein Boss.
Oder irgendwas, was sau viel aushält.
Aber hauptsache mal gesägt, ne?
Hauptsache mal gesägt.
Ach, Relon.
Alter, da kommt ja schon wieder ein Kleinviecher.
Aber das ist geil, wenn du Dave hast, ne?
Dave macht den Kleinscheiß.
Da kommt noch mehr.
Oh, der hatte eine Grenade drauf, ne?
Nee, das war Dave's Stun-Nade oder sowas.
Oh, guck mal. Eine Granate.
Hä?
Ich glaub, ich kann X drücken, aber keine Ahnung.
Andere Seite.
Hier, du kannst nichts drücken.
Ah, okay.
Alter, nimm das!
Boah, Digga, ist das dein Ernie?
Haben wir noch eine Granate?
Jawoll.
Ach, das ist so ein K.K.
Ja.
So, jetzt kommen wir zurück zu Shotgun.
Bam.
Ich glaube, da hinten ist einer mit Schneiber.
Nächster Shotgun. Bam.
Das ging noch um den Sack.
Vor dir ist noch einer.
Vor mir ist noch einer.
Fuck, von rechts, oder?
Neben dir.
Ich weiß nicht von wo.
Ach, von da oben.
Links, links.
Jetzt von hier.
Da hinten ist ein Shotgun.
Warum halten die so viel aus?
Das ist weg.
Ganz oben sind auch noch welche.
Die halten uns nicht aus.
Mit der Shotgun geht's halbwegs.
Bei dir kommt einer rein von links.
Fuck, ich hab kaum noch Munni.
Bist du down?
Nee, nee, das ist Dave.
Dave ist down.
Alter, ich blick grad nicht mal durch.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Da ist jetzt ein Fliegeviecher am Start.
Au.
Da kann man nicht drüber springen.
Alter, ich glaube...
Ich glaub, das sind jetzt irgendwelche Bossviecher.
Die halten möglichst viel aus.
Au.
Da, fuck.
Die müssen weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Na ja.
Haben wir noch irgendeine Granate oder sowas?
Ich hab grade vier Stück reingeschmissen.
Die haben uns nicht gespaßt.
Die scharten hier rum und halten möglichst viel aus.
Okay, einer ist down.
Brauch Munni, Munni, Munni. Hier.
Hinter uns, hinter uns, links.
Gut, ich aim.
Okay, next to down.
So.
Ey, wie der Typ OI sagt, trinkert mich voll.
OI.
Das wird ganz schön anstrengend, ne?
Ja. Wir sind doch nicht mehr gewohnt, ey.
OI.
OI, Freehead, OI.
Wenn ich das nur irgendwie umtransportieren könnte, das wär geil.
Äh, wo kommt das?
Wo kommt das?
Da vorne hier.
Oh, das, das, das
das chargt sich irgendwie.
Haben wir nicht noch irgendwas hier?
Irgendwas mit, mit, äh,
Explosivgeschiss vom Liegen?
Au! Fuck!
Was war das denn?
Ja!
Aber hier, der, der Coal, der Coaldrain.
Ich weiß nicht, was das war. Wahrscheinlich
das Bossviech oder so.
Alter, das kommt hoch, ne?
Moment, ich geh mal ans Geschütz.
Oh, fuck!
Das Geschütz geht in die andere Richtung.
Oh mein Gott.
Komm! Komm!
So ist die richtig down.
Nee, ich lebe! Goll!
Man kann den von hinten
anschießen, das macht in der ganzen Ecke mehr
Damage.
Okay, was auch immer mit dem Viech abgeht, aber
das hält auf jeden Fall viel aus.
Einfach, einfach durch die
Hecke stelzen.
Heckenstelz geht immer.
The fuck!
Ja!
Oh!
Hab dich.
Alles klar.
Morgen, KS.
Ich glaub, wir stellen uns alle mit den letzten Menschen, ey.
Nee, das ist keine Ahnung.
Get over here!
Das macht mega Damage.
Nein!
Okay, reload.
Alter, das hat mich mit seinem
komischen Strackkopf gesetzt und dann ist es
gesprungen und hat mich...
Ich glaub, das macht übelst Damage.
Das ist Monka Kiga, ey.
Hoffentlich müssen wir den ganzen Scheiß
nicht nochmal machen.
Oi!
Ich glaub, wir müssen aber kurz noch das
große Blechen rausnehmen.
Wenigstens ordentlicher Checkpoint.
Nicht triggernd, so wie der Typ sagt, oi.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Oi!
Ich guck mal, ob man die von links irgendwie...
Was?
Hebt sich denn auf,
weil ich bin auf der anderen Seite.
Ich glaub, wenn es sich chargt,
muss man einfach wegrollen
oder so.
Ich schieße jetzt auf den Schwanz.
Oh, hier, gucke mal.
Ich brauch... Money, Money.
Come on, Big Mama!
Legt hier noch irgendwo was rum?
Ich hab...
Ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Wo haben wir denn
den Petten gekillt?
Ich glaube,
die Munition ist mit dem Reload verschwunden,
oder?
Keine Munition mehr.
Alter.
Boah, fuck, ich komm.
Nee, ich bin
über so weit unten.
Ich werd jetzt gebannt.
Komm, oder lebst du wieder?
Frag mich, wie man das hier benutzt.
Sag mal, hatte ich das irgendwie
im Bauch, oder was?
Ach nee, der Coal war das.
In Deckung?
Jawoll. Okay, man muss einfach nur in Deckung gehen,
wenn du das da mit seinem komischen
Dachelding rumstellst.
Hier liegt übrigens
nix mit Munition rum, das ist Sack,
ziemlich.
I don't know, wie das funktionieren soll.
Einfach bashen.
Ich versuch gerade diese Waffe nicht zu checken.
Hast du was mit Granatwerfer?
Ja.
Nee, ich hab hier sowas nicht.
Einfach bashen.
Fast down.
Müsst es nicht komplizierter machen, als es ist.
Wir müssen unter den Bauch
schießen, sagt der Chat.
Ja, stimmt, aber da muss erst mal
hinkommen.
Egal, ist trotzdem fast dauernd.
X-Bot. Jawoll.
Schreckt.
Ich hab nur Müllwaffen.
Ich auch.
Vor allem die Mobs, die vorher da waren.
Äh, die sind weg.
No personal items, no luggage.
Held drauf.
Dad?
No personal items.
Warum ist der Typ, der Typ eigentlich,
warum muss da so einer aufs Bast machen?
Give a lot of people a life today, Sarge.
Haha, the Grub-Killer retires, baby.
Grub-Killer, Swarm-Killer, whatever.
Yeah, rescued
by my old trainees.
Uncle Clay!
Kennt man die Typen eigentlich, oder die Mädels?
Yeah, and now I got...
Nie wirklich, oder?
I was getting worried, you didn't report back.
Daniel died, and these guys pulled me out of a jam.
Guess I owe you twice, Felix.
Streamt ihr öfters zusammen?
Wir würden generell öfters zusammen streamen,
wenn wir Games hätten, die wir zusammen spielen können, ne?
Ja.
Oh.
Bronka.
Ah, Carmine ist tot.
Carmine muss immer sterben, in jedem Gears, ne?
Ne, geht ja gar nicht.
Was tot ist, ist tot.
Ja, aber das ist doch...
Die haben doch ne riesen Familie bei Gears,
die Carmine-Typen.
Das ist immer ein anderer Carmine.
Minecraft? Ne, wir spielen kein Minecraft.
Minecraft!
Das ging anders.
Du hast damals gesagt, ihr mein...
Minecraft!
Nur so ist's original.
Es ist sehr sinnvoll, loszufliegen
mit dem Heli, wenn du...
wenn du so Stelldrohnen hast,
die dich bashen, ne?
Big Brain.
Ich charge da jetzt rein.
Ich hab nur Müllwaffen, Alter.
Und wie funktioniert diese komische Waffe?
Ich hab auch übelste Crap-Waffen nur.
Kann man sich Waffen highlighten lassen?
Irgendwie, ne?
Oh, hier, guck mal,
hier gibt's Upgrade-Shit.
Ach ne, das ist ne Herdplatte, keine Waffe da drin.
Oh, wir haben jetzt drei Punkte,
wir können Dave upgraden.
Ne, wir haben fünf.
Fünf Stück schon eingesammelt.
Ich glaub, hier können wir nicht weiter.
Wo ging das mit dem Upgrade?
Warte mal, ich guck mal.
Oh, das war ne schlechte Idee.
Ich bin ins Feuer gelaufen.
Lol.
Grafik sieht mal richtig gut aus.
Ja, für das, dass wir das auf der normalen Xbox spielen,
also wir haben ja nicht mal ne Xbox X,
aber Gears sah schon immer gut aus.
Das erste Gears war für seine Zeit am besten.
Ja.
Kann man das überspringen?
Ja, ich guck mal.
Ne, es loadet noch,
ich darf's nicht überspringen.
Gibt es Neuigkeiten von Fiverr, ja?
Zehn haben abgesagt,
einer hat was geliefert.
Von was?
Fiverr. Fiverr ist so ne Plattform,
da kannst du so kreative Leute beauftragen,
für dich Bilder zu malen,
irgendwelche Musiksachen komponieren zu lassen und so.
Okay.
Also, ich hab mich beauftragt auf Fiverr,
was zu programmieren,
was wir im Stream schon mal gemacht haben.
Also, elf hab ich beauftragt,
zehn haben abgesagt,
einer im Inder hat was geliefert
und das ist mega schlecht.
Richtig RIP.
Unsere Waffen sacken, ne?
Meine sacken richtig,
ich hab nur Müllwaffen, die nicht funktionieren.
Wo geht's denn lang?
Was gibt's denn hier eigentlich?
Schaschlik und Steak.
Okay, hier rauf ich die nochmal rein.
Oh, was gibt's hier?
Mr. Chipsauce.
Chipsauce?
Wo gibt's Mr. Chipsauce?
Wo ist denn der?
Da ist der Friesi.
Guck mal, jetzt gibt's Fischchips und...
Party Crunch.
Proteinsnacks.
Proteinsnacks ist auch was für die Gears-Typen hier.
Guck mal, die halten sogar Shotgun aus.
Okay, Fisch in Chips ist auch nicht schlecht.
Spicy.
Also ich nehm Spicy Albert.
Nee.
Spicy Saltberry.
Haha, ich hab irgendwie Spicy Albert.
Ich nehm Proteinsnacks.
100% Biological.
Das ist Bio, ja.
Ja, steht da.
Vegan ist auch vegan.
Und Traditional Recipe.
Ich seh's gar nicht.
Sagt man das Rezept auf Englisch?
Welche Tüte?
Bei Proteinsnacks links.
Wie spricht man das aus?
Wenn ich das lesen konnte.
Oh, jetzt kann man's nicht mehr lesen.
Na, Rezept auf Englisch.
Recipe.
Ah, genau.
Hier darfst du nicht reinrennen.
Deshalb bin ich gerade reingerannt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Guck mal, hier müssen wir wieder Türstelz machen.
Oh, Türstelz? Ah, Türstelz.
Ich bräuchte jetzt aber meine Waffe.
Ich auch.
Uh.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was es macht, aber
huge.
Ich seh's ja.
Achso, wir müssen ausrüsten.
Okay.
Equip. Post. Acht. Nee.
Support.
Nee, das ist kostenlos.
Was war das, dass es Enemy stellt?
Jack gibt's Temporary
Armor Boost. Oh, das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Ah, das ist geil.
Brauch ich für Shotgun Bash.
So.
So, warte mal, wir können aber noch was skillen.
Hier, hier gibt's, hier gibt's Armor.
Du, warte mal, wir können hier noch was skillen.
Skillen wir denn hier? Wir haben 8 Points.
Bashen. Skill immer.
Zephyr for longer.
Was haben wir hier? Wollen wir noch ein bisschen
Health machen? Ja. Genau.
So, Health kann Dave nie haben. Guck mal, wir können Health.
Ach, guck mal, man kann jetzt auch active
reloaden, wenn man keine
Muni rausgeschossen hat aus der Waffe.
Guck mal,
reviven, das passt erst mal.
Oh, das ist ein cooler
Sound.
Was, was ist jetzt mit Waffe?
Du kannst active reloaden, ohne dass
du einen Schuss abgefeuert haben musst aus der Waffe.
Achso, ja.
Achso, nee, das ging früher nicht.
Nee, kannst du, nee.
Eigentlich. Weil dann ist es grau.
Siehst du?
Wenn du es machst und nicht geschossen hast,
kriegst du keine active reload, nur das Ding ist
Nee, mach mal, lad mal,
schieß mal und lad mal nach. Und dann mach mal,
also mach immer active reload.
Oh, bin ich dumm, oder was?
Und wenn du es
das zweite Mal machst, ist der active reload grau.
Achso, ja, hast recht.
Ja, ja.
Aber danach kannst du es gleich nochmal machen.
Danach kannst du es gleich nochmal machen und dann geht's.
Okay, wo, wo, wo geht's lang?
Wir haben uns gerade Ammoboost gegeben.
Ja. Moment.
Stim? Wir brauchen den Scan.
Alter, ohne Scan finden wir doch nie, wo es lang geht.
Hä, wie dumm ist das denn?
Sagt alle.
Achso, nee, wir können ja noch diesen anderen nehmen, da.
Nee.
Ich will Dave wieder, Dave war besser.
So, jetzt lass mal gucken, wo es denn hier lang geht.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn, ey. So ein komisches
rumgestelltes hier.
So, wo geht's dann? Aber wir wollen da gar nichts.
Ja, dann lass Stim wieder rausbacken.
Hä, das ist aber total dumm.
Das ist mega dumm. Warte mal.
So, jetzt.
Hier zuvor ist nur noch Gears, ja.
Weiß nicht warum, weil
weil Gears
weil wahrscheinlich war, weiß nicht.
Hier lang? Alter, wo geht's?
Ah, guck mal beim Feuer, doch, beim Feuer.
Ach, wir müssen unserem Feuer einen Boost geben.
Achso.
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich auch nicht. Komm, wir machen mal das andere wieder rein.
Ich komm, ich komm, angewetzt.
Wo musst du? Ich drück Y jetzt.
Wir stellen uns nebeneinander und drücken einfach mal Y.
Y?
Ja. Ah, siehst du?
Ah.
Oh, next level.
Next level, ja.
Ich brauch mal...
900 mindestens, also das war...
Da reichen 200 nicht für.
Okay, was gibt's hier? Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Oh, da ist was.
Alter, gibt's eine Pistole hier?
Was ist das?
Oh.
Stim-Time.
Stim-Time. Bist du da?
Oder wollen wir erstmal...
Lass uns erstmal hinten in Ruhe gucken, ob da irgendwas ist.
Ist aber nix, ne?
Nee.
Okay, dann stimmen wir uns jetzt durchs Feuer.
Bist du da?
Ja.
Das ist aber schon wieder ne ganz coole Idee.
Ja, find ich auch, ne?
Wow.
Äh...
Haben die wenigstens Waffen gehabt?
Oh, da geht's ink.
Alter, ich brauch ne Waffe.
Da liegen nur Waffen rum hier auf der Erde.
Fuck, Alter.
Ah, geht down.
Hier.
Gar nicht so viele Gegner.
Habe ich irgendwas zum schneiden?
Oh ja, hier, Schneider. Achtung jetzt.
Bam.
Steh auf.
Bam. Jawoll.
Dann sind sie geschneidert mit der Pistole.
Komm her.
Bam. Hä?
Warum hat das nicht getroffen?
Jawoll, letzter Down.
Guten Tag.
Oh fuck, die Pistole ist leer.
Okay, mal runter sliden.
Bist du da oben drin mit der Shotgun gerade?
Nee, mit nem anderen Waffen.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, sie sind tot.
Wollen wir hier durch?
Warte.
Wir haben ein paar Waffen.
Overkill? Nee, das ist das, was ich...
Enforcer.
Ich nehme einfach das.
Ist sowieso eine Mini-Uzi.
Was ist denn Overkill?
Ist das Shotgun, oder?
Hm...
Sackt.
Ach so, hier oben war ich, ja.
Hier ist auch noch meine Overkill.
Oh Mann, ich hab noch meine...
Hier ist Shotgun.
Mr. Seegors.
Ich hab ja nix zum Sägen.
Primulon Stufe 1, dankeschön.
Lutsch Bigbrainz ab. Da unten liegt was.
Hammer Burst.
Du hast 11.
Grenades, brauer.
Hast du?
Chocnate.
Smoke?
Nebelkerze raus.
Ich glaube beim ersten Gears war das. Nebelkerze raus.
Aha, ja. Alles klar.
Nice Story. Cool Story, Bro.
CSB.
Okay, wo geht's weiter?
Sag mal, geht's dir auch so, dass es teilweise von mir ist, wo es lang geht?
Dabei ist Gears übel straight forward. Hier geht's lang.
Gut, mein Problem ist dieses Ding eigentlich drücken immer wieder. Wird ja angezeigt, ne?
Hier, komm mal durch die Tür.
Boah, Tee, Trox 04. Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Du, früher waren die Dinger nicht so verwinkelt. Da gab's immer nur so ähnlich.
Ja, geradeaus.
Immer geradeaus.
Oh, hier ist ein Lancer.
Ich nehm den Lancerino.
Das ist eine coole Grafik hier jetzt mit der Beleuchtung.
Oh, guck mal, hier ist ein Cocktag.
Oh.
Guck mal, 1444 schon.
Willst du deinen Longshot nicht behalten?
Nee, Longshot jetzt hier in den Gängen ist doch nie so geil.
Okay, weiter geht's. Aber hier...
Oh, hier muss der Bob...
Komm, wie komm ich auf Bob?
Ach, ich weiß noch, denn Fallout hieß Bob, oder?
Kann sein.
Das ist schon geil gemacht.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Oh, hier, guck mal, da ist so ein neues Vieh.
Das wartet auf uns, um in gebasht werden.
Ich will uns jetzt richtig schneeben.
Au.
Okay, Shotgun raus.
Alter, wie lange brauchst du zum Nachladen?
Oh, die explodieren ja nochmal extra.
Okay, jetzt holen wir mal die Shotgun raus.
So, jetzt brauchen wir ein bisschen Muni.
Ich brauche Mun. Wo war das denn?
Wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Wo war das denn? Ich brauche Mun.
War das auch hier?
Ich brauche Mun.
Oder?
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube es war hier.
Ich brauche Mun.
Hier ist ein Hammer Burst.
Ja, den habe ich da gerade hingeschmissen.
Den kann ich nicht.
Hier entforstet sich es gerade.
Hier, noch mehr. Nehm die Muni.
Verlischt.
Ich bin schon voll mit Enforcer, Dude.
Ah, dann entforce ich noch eine Runde.
Okay, nice, weiter.
Alter!
Oh, Monkaes.
Dahinter ist auch noch ein Hauch und so.
Aber das Gute ist, wenn der Erste explodiert, explodiert der Zweite auch mit.
Ja.
Oh, hier eine Nashor, aber ich glaube das ist nicht so geil, um zu Nashornieren.
Ah, schadet nichts.
Ich nehme mit.
Kann Max den Chat ingame eigentlich sehen?
Also, ich sehe den Chat, ich schaffe den auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
Aber im Game sehe ich ihn nicht.
Ne, ne.
Da ist nur Overlay.
Overkill?
Wow, fuck!
Was sagt du jetzt, Alter?
Um zu Nashorn ist freudig, ist hart.
Dieser Overkill ist auch nicht entfordert.
Die, die Enforcer ist überfordert.
Oh, fuck.
Mir fällt die equipped backwards auf.
Die, die Enforcer ist übelst freudig im Smartware.
Oh, oh, oh, hinter dir.
Okay, jetzt wird sie geschottgun.
Geht nicht anders.
Jetzt müsste sie shotgun werden.
Oh Gott, es werden immer mehr.
Alter, die ist richtig freudig.
Oh!
Wir sind voll in der Ecke.
Alter, der Typ kommt hier hinterher gekrappelt.
Ich 빤níhuay系 곰 demonstration.
The whole team is behind me.
Ich hab nur einen Shotgun-Schuss. Ich hab nur noch ein bisschen Enforcer-Ammo, ich hab kaum noch was.
Geben wir uns mal einen.
Ja, gute Idee.
Okay, Munni ist all.
Die Muni, ne?
Die Mun. Da ist was. Da steht was rum.
Noch einer, oder was?
Den kann man nahe kampfen.
Nahe-Nahe-Kampf.
Ich hab keine Munni.
Nichts.
Ich hab drei Knäscherschüsse.
Na gut, ich hab im Enforcer noch was drin und diesen komischen Pistol.
Okay, hier liegt jetzt was rum. 100 pro.
Ah, Enforcer.
Vielleicht kann man jetzt mit dem Dave irgendwas machen.
Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Der Dave stelzt hier über uns rum.
Der Dave stelzt über uns.
Warum stelzt der Dave so?
Und es sieht nicht normal aus.
Ich zieh den jetzt einfach an.
Alter, verzieh die.
Jingle-Kuro und Elektronik-Tee.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Twitch Prime-Subs.
Was ist hier?
Was ist da los?
Hier, da ist noch einer.
Wir lassen einfach den Dave, den lasern.
Der hat ja Neon endlich zum Stühnen.
Bist du gestühnt?
Ach so, stimmt.
Wenn wir das ausgebildet hätten, könnte man den...
...inschicken, glaube ich sogar.
Echt, wir haben ja noch ein paar Skill-Points.
Nee, ich kann nicht drauf.
Da sind alle reingehauen.
Oh, brauchst du den?
Aha, meins.
Bei 60 plus, Alter.
Ich hab nur noch einen Nasher.
Da steht noch so ein...
Das kann man Nahkampfplatten machen.
Das können wir vielleicht sogar sägen.
Au!
Hahaha.
Lebst du wieder?
Ja.
Okay, jetzt ist alles weg.
Ich brauch noch Muni.
Give pleats.
Give energy.
Hier liegt nix, ne?
Hier ist alles keine Muni.
Hier ist noch ein Forza-Muni.
Ja.
Aber ein Lancer ist hier.
Ich hab meinen Shotgun weggeworfen.
Ich kann nicht.
Da kommt er gleich, ey.
Okay, weiter.
Ja.
Das finde ich so dumm, dass die nicht mehr vorbeifahren.
Wenn du Exit Reload triffst.
Ja.
Du wusstest vor allem auch immer, dass es drinnen war.
Ohne oben hingucken zu müssen, ne?
Hier ist Muni, guck mal.
Links.
Ich nehm das mal.
Jetzt kann ich scheren.
Guck mal, jetzt können wir Muni scheren, glaube ich.
Bleib mal stehen.
Nein.
Aber mach.
Jetzt hast du das Lancer-Muni gekriegt.
Hier ist auch irgendwas.
Big Brain.
Ey.
Lieber Kitty Cat.
Das war ein Einbruch.
Was soll das denn sein?
Ob's die noch gibt?
Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, ob's die noch gibt.
Hier gibt's richtig viel, Mann.
Jetzt haben wir ordentlich Muni am Start.
Kann gebasht werden.
Was liegt dort?
Links.
Muni.
Bist du ready?
Ich hatte so lange schon keinen Controller mehr in der Hand, dass mir richtig Finger fliegen.
Ja, mir auch.
Voll ungewohnt.
Richtig schlecht.
Oh, oh, bashen.
Oh, warte.
Oh.
Oh, ich muss auch nach draußen.
Ich muss nach draußen.
Oh, da.
Wo ist meine Shotgun?
Entfrau meine Shotgun.
Alter, das sind übelst viele.
Haben wir eine Granate oder so?
Ja, hier.
Wo bist du?
Irgendwo über uns ist was.
Rechts, rechts.
Die halten ein komplettes Magazin aus, die dudes.
Ja.
Ich glaub, das ist absichtlich so gemacht, dass du nicht in deiner Deckung sitzen kannst
und drei Stunden hast.
Und das hier?
Oh, da ist ein Klo.
Oh, nice!
Das hat...
Alter, nicht hinwerfen das Ding.
Wo sind sie?
Hinter mir.
Alter, das Ding ist überhitzt.
Ui!
Okay, nice.
Next.
GG.
Next no re.
Was gibt's denn hier eigentlich?
Was ist denn das?
Was?
Oh, ist der runtergezinkt, oder?
Ja, war der.
Der ist doch hier.
Oh, da ist eine Klo.
Oh, die sind nicht da.
Wollen wir diese Runde singen, oder?
Das ist die komische Shotgun, ne?
Die hat die von uns schon weggeworfen.
Das Game hat eh nur die einen Tigirs Shotgun, der Rest suckt.
Äh, nein.
Manchmal ist, wenn man zu zweit spielt, noch dümmer, ne?
Dann geht der eine an der Tür und der andere geht mit, nur weil er denkt, er muss die Tür jetzt mit aufmachen.
Obwohl die Tür überhaupt nicht aufgeht.
Ob die aufgeht hier? Nee.
Wir drücken jetzt einfach mal LB.
Doch, hier. Hier B.
Shit, shit, shit.
Warum werden eigentlich immer nur die geschreckt von diesem Zeug und wir nicht?
Weil wir die geilen Flasche entzünden.
Ich wurde auch fast getrackt, gerade.
Ja, nur fast. Das ist halt der Unterschied.
Waren wir hier nicht schon?
Nee, sieht einfach nur genau so aus.
Oh.
Dave!
Wir sollen den jetzt killen.
Aufballern.
Skiers.
Alles bashen.
Es wird schon kleiner, siehste?
Ja, jetzt holen wir uns mal weg hier, he?
Ich glaub, das Ding ist zu doof, die Treppe zu gehen.
Wenn man Treppenstelts macht, passiert dann nix.
Wobei, wird das wirklich... Ja, das wird kleiner, oder?
Alter, die verzieht, ey.
Huge aim, huge aim, alter.
Sieht fast so aus.
Ich find, das wird kleiner.
Alter, ne.
Früher hat man mal gebasht, ey, auf der Konsole.
Vor allem hast du nicht zu mir gesagt, das verlernt man nie.
Doch.
Aber du müsstest mit dem 360-Controller spielen, dann würdest du auch besser treffen. Ohne Scheiß jetzt.
Mit dem 360-Controller treff ich auch noch besser.
Zwar nicht gut, aber besser.
Das kam mit dem Elite eigentlich gut zurecht.
Na gut, du hast ja... Na gut, stimmt, nee, dann nicht.
Ha?
Dann nicht. Ich dachte, du hast halt einen Controller, dem du nicht gewohnt bist.
Aber du spielst ja...
Nee, ich hab ja Gears... Ich hab ja Gears Ultimate richtig gesuchtet.
Also richtig, richtig gesuchtet, aber ich kann gar nix.
Außer Active Reload, das klappt ganz gut.
Das ist auch das Einzige, was ich hinkrieg.
Ja.
Das war aber doch früher auch nicht so anstrengend. Ich mein, wir haben das teilweise... Wir haben sieben Stunden am Stück gespielt, ja.
Wie geht das denn?
Ich bin einfach alt.
Du bist jetzt auch 35, oder?
Ja.
RIP.
Hier, können wir aufmachen.
Komme.
Mal gucken, wie sie die Tür jetzt öffnen, ob sie das mit Style machen, oder ob sie es wieder so... so low aufschieben.
Ja, so! So geht das, ne?
So muss...
So. Wo ist da was?
Haben wir noch... Haben wir noch Nate?
Nein.
Ich hab nur scheiße Ultimate aufgemacht.
Okay, wir können jetzt vor.
Ui!
Alter, was sind das für Teile?
Terminators.
Boah, das klingt halt ziehend übelst.
Aber wir stürmen... Wir stürmen sollen jetzt da mal mit vor.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Au!
Das seh ich in meinem übelsten Magen.
Wir bräuchten mal irgendwie... Oh ja, das Ding hier kann ein bisschen Damage machen.
Ich bleib mal hinten... Ich bleib mal in Deckung.
Das Ding out mich sonst.
Der ist...
Oh Leute, den hab ich gar nicht gesehen, Mann.
Oh, das macht... Das auf dem Kopf macht schön Damage.
Jawoll.
Oh, wie gehabt, ey.
Geto Recto.
Wie ist das hier?
Easy as fuck. Geto Recto.
Wollen Länze aufheben.
Ey, warum gibt's denn hier nur so eine kack Watte, Mann?
Ich hab nur Mühe, was ich noch nie gespielt hab, Mann.
Ich glaub das ist aber absichtlich diesmal, dass die Munition ein bisschen knapper gemacht haben.
Dass man mehr unterschiedliches Zeug nimmt und nicht so rumcampt.
Ja, sicher nicht.
Oh, oh, das ist ja so ein Viech.
Ach, diesmal kann man's nicht killen.
Diesmal kann man's nicht killen, das Ding.
Glaub ich.
Oder?
Kann man's jetzt doch killen?
Ich seh jetzt noch mal eine Uschi von unten.
Oh, was ist das?
Oh ja, huge.
Huge Damage.
Alter.
Das Ding überhitzt.
Fuck, jetzt ist es leer.
99 Schuss von so einer Müllwaffe, ey.
Ja.
се HR Äh, La Ich kann ich was nicht gehofft!
Ah, ja.
Ja.
Ja, das sehr schön, bitte.
Wull ich mich jetzt aus dem Griff layoutschrecken.
directions go!
Geil Mensch, na toll.
Sorry.
Okay.
Wer saved-sign?
boost?
Ja.
Ich habe eine Overkill und einen Lancer, also eine Shotgun, äh, ich habe Overkill und einen Enforcer.
Eine Shotgun und einen Nahkampf.
Ähm, also ne...
Ja, aber so mehr gibt es hier nicht.
Den Friseur gibt es doch, ja, den gibt es doch.
Also hier gibt es nichts.
Alles, alles leer.
Ja, das habe ich bemerkt, aber es gibt schon viel da drüben.
Was ist das für eine Kontrolle?
Ich schaue mir das mal an.
Großbrain.
Der Schauspieler, was ist sein Name? Äh, äh, Jace Stratton.
Er war in der Spiel-Runde hier, oder?
Wenn ihr euch überrascht, dann nicht.
Jace kann sich umgehen.
Keiner hier zurück.
Lass uns den Stag schauen.
Nein?
Nein, nein, passt.
Nein, ich glaube, hier geht es weiter.
Oder? Oder?
Ne, hier waren wir noch nie.
Oh, hier kannst du es aufheben.
Oh.
Ja, oh.
Muss man, ah, hier muss man aufstelzen.
Kate ist fein, ne?
Muss die Tür boxen.
Ah, Kate?
Ja.
Gerade 2000.
Und 11 Flashbacks.
Ja, da waren wir noch.
Da haben wir nicht so was getroffen mit dem Controller.
Ich habe mal meine Sensitivity runtergestellt, ich glaube, das passt jetzt.
Weißt du, das bringt was?
Mach ich jetzt auch mal.
Du, ich habe übelst hoch gehabt.
Ja, von.
Ja, Look Sensitivity 10 habe ich jetzt.
Ja, bei mir war es 15, 18, 15.
Und was hast du jetzt?
10.
Überall.
10, 12, 10.
Und auch Aim Acceleration, Inner Deadzone und so.
Ich glaube, ja.
Also alle drei, die man einstellen kann.
Okay, ah, dann.
Ich habe früher erwähnt, da habe ich 20, 25, 20 gespielt.
Okay.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht immer irgendwas treffen mit der Einstellung.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber 10, 12, 10 fühlt sich jetzt irgendwie so danach an.
Aber das ist mega langsam.
Dafür triffst du was.
Aber auf die Kante würde ich was treffen.
Ja.
Fair Story.
Da wird er rangeslidet.
Okay.
Alter, gibt es jetzt hier mal irgendwas geiles?
Gibt es was zu bashen?
Gibt es jetzt?
Oh, ne.
Das sieht nach Boss aus.
Patroda.
Kannst du was essen?
Kannst du, kannst du mir jetzt zugucken, wie gebasht wird?
Wow.
Oh, jetzt ekelt es richtig.
MonkaS.
Wow.
Das schießt den, das Kappa kaputt.
Alter, die Muskeln.
Die Muskeln.
Alter, die Musik.
MonkaS.
Oh, ist der Farz und Jazz.
Oh, hier gibt es Lanzarino.
Ey, der ist einfach.
Oh ne, da kommen so ne Fetten.
Alter.
Muss weg.
Au.
Ich lebe hier.
Ich schiebe mich gleich auf den.
Ich seh jetzt.
Oh.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ich will mich nicht mehr aufhören.
Alter, was ist das hier?
Fuck!
Alter.
Ich bin hinter der Säule.
Krass, ist der gut.
Stehst du wieder?
Ja.
Hier ist noch einer.
Hier hinten, der ist down.
Der ist fast down, der Vieh.
Ja.
Eats, Eats AF.
Die Musik.
Noll, Alter.
So, jetzt.
Der Lanz am Riemen.
Oh, mir tut übelst die linke Hand weh.
Ich bin Kontroll-Aussteuerung überhaupt nicht gewohnt mehr.
Oh nein.
Pain Champ.
Ronny.
Ich brauche Moon.
Ich hab Moon.
Aber nur Krackwaffen.
Ey, hier liegen jede Menge Overkills rum, die keiner haben will.
Nö, Overkills suck.
Okay.
Geht's lang?
Rein die...
...Hütten.
...Tür.
Jetzt mal hier den Haufen angucken.
Die sagen gleich tot alles, ne?
Alles down.
Oh, hast du das kleine Teil, oder was?
Ja, aber das ähm...
Kannst ja nicht durch die...
Kannst ja nicht durch die Tür mitnehmen.
Oh.
Fuck.
Weg.
Gut, dass ich's mitgenommen hab.
Geh.
Geh vor ihr.
Ah, Kindeschnupp.
Ah, doch.
Ist mir fast lieber als der...
Schnupp.
Was ist ihr Status?
Lizzie made it.
Was?
Wait, was ist ihr jeune weiß nuevo?
Ja, ja.
Komm zaten schon seins.
Ah, ich hab L outfits schon.
Dieses ist ja...
Dadox.
Ach komm.
Das ist...
Aber das ist doch rice, Freunde.
Nee, nee.
Das ist L нick الم.
Ihr helft ihne.
Immerhin.
Was ist denn das hier?
Wha...
Wie sagt der closure?
Aber Lyري?
ADOX.
Oh, 선물.
Neam's da?
So soll er da sein.
Wie?
Na, der ist halt...
Ja...
Es ist schoniuos...
ihrem communicator ans ohr gehalten jack freck jack freck jack fett und das
bauherr jetzt lang hast du irgendwas unten aber hier könnte man noch aufs
klo gehen ist der kack so was jetzt sie katz katz katz was ist die rennt
draußen rum und guckt kannst du gucken wie gebärscht wird
der morgenröte
kalt rein
jetzt wirklich egal vielleicht ist mittlerweile schon rassistisch wenn die
schwarze altern lässt also da war es ja nie
ist noch das teil du meinst das unterirdische teil war das glaube ich
nicht
ich kann mich gar nicht daran erinnern
ok ok das war das
klar dass das was das ist oder
glaube nicht dass das ist das oben vielleicht
ich glaube man muss den so ist hier unten auch die auf die kugel am bauch
Ja, das ist gut.
Vielleicht sitzt hier einer so stehen und ihr basht den von hinten.
Easy.
Jetzt hat er keinen Bock mehr.
Ist klar!
Das funktioniert natürlich auch so gut.
Oh.
Jetzt bin ich aber nicht mehr hinter ihm.
What the fuck?
She baited.
Das Ding am Bein musste basht werden.
Jawoll.
Schreck.
Das war nicht so schwer jetzt.
Das war einfach irgendwie.
Ich glaube wir haben ganz gut die Agro verteilt halt.
Genau.
Größe ist nicht alles.
Was?
Ich sag Größe ist nicht alles.
Ey Fiesch.
Wir haben die Agro verteilt.
Hast du schön getauntet.
Ja.
Aber das sind Schreie.
Verdammte Wiese.
Wow.
Wo habe ich denn News vercken?
Wisst ihr wer den ersten Schuss gebucht hat?
directly
Verenigte Vespa Proteste
von eurer.
Ich glaube vier Stück?
Also heute schaffen wir das nicht mehr.
Vor allem nicht,
wenn du morgen um acht aufstehen musst.
Nee, du musst nicht um acht aufstehen.
Du musst um acht Hellst czym machen.
Durchspielen schaffen wir definitiv nicht, ich denke mal das werden keine Ahnung, ich
denke mal die Story wird nie bloß, ne ich denke auch mal, wahrscheinlich so 7-8 Stunden
oder so.
Ich glaube, ne heutzutage sind doch die Games nicht mehr so kurz oder?
Ne die sind eher kürzer als früher, noch kürzer?
Oh da ist Lizzy am Start, ich weiß zwar nicht wer Lizzy ist, aber Lizzy ist am Start, irgendein
Core-Slut, ein Core-Grill, Pogas, na klar, was sonst, ne?
Hier müssen wir jetzt alle bashen, ne wir stelzen die nicht, wir rennen jetzt weg, hinter
uns kriegt die Wand ein und wir müssen weiter stelzen, irgendwie sowas, und wir müssen
Lizzy retten vielleicht.
Ach jetzt, jetzt wird doch gehämmert.
Nice.
Sind viele nuts?
By the way, richtig viele.
Oh, ich bin aus dem Game geflogen wahrscheinlich.
Oh ne, oder?
Kommt bei dir noch irgendwo?
Ja, ja, bei mir läuft hier noch die Zwischenreaktion.
Ey Frisi left the game.
Ist ja dumm.
Oh.
Weißt du wo wir uns noch über die Playstation 3 lustig gemacht haben, weil die Connection
zackt?
Oh.
Oh mein Gott, diese 分家
Leute ist genau so.
Ich guck mal, ob ich dich schon einladen kann.
Während der Zwischensequenz, ja.
Geht.
Kannst du schon mal loaden.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir auch keine Ports freigeschalten für die X-Bone.
Ja, aber ist egal.
Wenn es geht...
Fail to join.
Wahrscheinlich, weil wir in der Zwischensequenz kommen.
Ist eine gestreckt.
Gehämmert.
It's Hammer time.
Das muss natürlich unbedingt als Subtitle kommen, ne?
Bei mir steht aber auch irgendwie Dark Connecting.
Ich entwalte dich nach der Zwischensequenz wieder.
Es wäre richtig nice, wenn der jetzt einfach, wer das gesagt hat, direkt gehämmert wird und down ist.
Der Hammer ist kaputt.
Der hammert weiter.
Dramatische Musik.
Scheiße, die wird du verrecken jetzt, hä?
Weißt du, was das Problem an Gears Zwischensequenzen ist?
Du kennst die Charaktere nicht.
Die jucken dich nicht.
Ja doch, du wirst die schon kennen, wenn du aufmerksam die anderen Games gezockt hättest.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wer Lizzie ist.
You're more like the leader.
Ich probier dich nochmal einzuladen.
Geht's jetzt?
Ich glaube, das liegt aber irgendwie an meiner X-Bone, weil zwischendrin hat die nämlich gesagt,
dass du schnell klingst.
Doch, doch.
Und dann hat's meine Friends.
Ich glaub, das ist, falls es in der Zwischensequenz war.
Jetzt darfst du wahrscheinlich Kate spielen.
Nö, du spielst Kate.
Also, du könntest doch wechseln.
Aber ich bleib...
down.
Well, yeah.
So.
Bitte.
Unsere
Oh, nicht schon wieder.
Ja, es ist ja auch immer noch Zwischensequenz.
Dumm ey.
Aber ich habe das gestern schon gelesen, dass viele, wenn die zusammenzocken, einfach rausfliegen.
Zack.
Warum hat das Game eigentlich so drei Stunden lange Zwischensequenzen?
Gears halt.
Ja, aber das hatten die ersten Gears nicht.
Oh ja, doch.
Also nicht so lang wie jetzt, aber...
Vor allem Gears juckt halt die Story nicht irgendwie.
Wie können die sich eigentlich alle so geil
die Waffe auf den Rücken schnallen, so mit einer Hand?
Alle Magnet?
Guck mal, da kann er
50 Dinger in den Rücken schnallen.
Wer ist das überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung.
Outsider 1 ist das.
Stimmt.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Das ist Outsider 3.
So, jetzt, jetzt
entweide ich dich.
Das Spiel hat eine relativ hohe
Bash-Downtime, würde ich sagen.
Stimmt.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, wir haben bei der
3 auch fast
alles geskippt, ne?
Ja.
Es gibt mir immer alles.
Geht's jetzt?
Ich bin jetzt schon mal in der Party
und muss jetzt hier 20 Sekunden
connecten.
Ich muss sagen, optisch haben die sich schon Mühe gegeben.
Die Welt
sieht doch diesmal belebter aus.
Sonst war nämlich immer so
rechts und links eher
weniger, ne?
Ja, vor allem im ersten, da war ja nix.
Im ersten war ja nix.
Im ersten war einfach alles kaputt.
Also Singleplayer hat mir der erste
immer noch am besten gefallen.
Da haben sie einfach gar nicht so getan, als hätten sie
große Story.
Och man, was ist das für ein Scheiß.
Was ist denn das jetzt für ein
Was ist das jetzt eigentlich für ein Chapter?
Okay, das ist das erste.
Weißt du, was wir jetzt machen? Willst du mal aufmachen?
Wir sind jetzt Anfang
Anfang, wir sind jetzt
Akt 2 Recruitment Drive.
Okay, dann mach du mal auf.
Also ich muss auf Host Game, ne?
Ja, du gehst auf
Kampagne.
Nee, nicht neues Game.
Nee, was machst du denn?
Custom oder was?
Ja, auf Kampagne, da musst du ein GSF Game auswählen.
So hab ich ja nie.
Ja, aber du kannst den Akt einstellen, wahrscheinlich,
weil du ihn gespielt hast.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du links den Akt selecten.
Guck mal.
Die Ladezeiten sind nicht mehr normal.
Select Chapter.
Was sind wir?
Akt 2.
Akt 3.
Irgendwas mit Drive.
Recruitment Drive.
Ja genau.
Ja stimmt.
So und jetzt?
Das fällst du raus und dann invidest du mich.
Und ich möchte nicht Jack spielen.
Ja, können wir ja wechseln.
Du kannst nicht Jack spielen, du musst der spielen.
Offline, aber...
Send in white.
Cool.
Gut.
Please wait. Processing in white.
Resident Sleeper.
Waiting, okay.
Tut sich was. Ah!
Bin am Start.
Kann starten.
Sollen wir uns das nochmal angucken, oder?
Oh, warte mal, ich kann RB, LB?
Wechsel.
Okay, gibt.
Hey, Max!
Oh Gott. Was ist? Sind wir jetzt zweimal Dell?
Nee, geht ja nicht.
Nee, aber wahrscheinlich kriegst du jetzt random eben zugeteilt
und darfst jetzt als Jack.
Es gibt nur zwei.
Nee, drei.
Stimmt, wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt echt Jack.
Das muss ja nicht sein.
Aber die Ladenzeiten
sind echt lang.
You have been removed from the game.
Ich glaube,
der Scheiß ist gerade verbuggt und funktioniert
nicht.
Münster?
Ja, übelster Crap.
Sacklein.
Warum?
Wo ist das Problem?
Weißt du, früher haben wir uns lustig gemacht,
dass du auf der Playstation immer so Probleme hast.
Mittlerweile läuft der Xbox auch nicht besser.
Wir können einfach morgen weiterspielen.
Können wir auch machen, klar.
Ja, lass morgen weiterspielen.
Ich meine, es ist 22 Uhr 20
und das Game geht nicht mehr.
Dann spielen wir morgen weiter.
Ja.
Dann machen wir jetzt erstmal Streben aus, dann können wir nochmal kurz schwätzen,
wenn wir morgen anfangen.
Ja, dann kann ich auch mal Multiplayer ausprobieren,
falls der aufgeht.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns morgen.
Irgendwie Gamesprank drum.
Immer am Schluss, bis dann.
See you.